bon soirée et bienvenue à tous émissions
spéciales un an après le début de la
guerre en Ukraine nous sommes ensemble
pendant deux heures et demie avec des
invités exceptionnelles et puis deux
films deux documentaires dont un inédit
que vous allez découvrir le tout autour
d'une grande question un an après
l'Ukraine peut-elle gagner la guerre
nous sommes sur LCP c'est l'événement et
c'est parti
le 24 février 2022 Vladimir Poutine
envoyait ses chars en Ukraine Moscou
rêvait alors d'une guerre éclair un an
après les Ukrainiens sont meurtri mais
le pays croit plus que jamais en sa
victoire alors est-ce que l'Ukraine peut
gagner cette guerre bonsoir Isabelle
Lasserre bonsoir Myriam et bienvenue sur
ce plateau que vous connaissez bien vous
êtes la correspondre en diplomatique du
Figaro la première journaliste française
à avoir
interviewéenski c'était à lire le 9
février dernier dans le Figaro on va y
revenir bonsoir général trinquant
Dominique trinquant ancien chef de la
mission militaire française à l'ONU
bonsoir Elsa Vidal et bienvenue sur ce
plateau spécialiste de la Russie
rédactrice en chef de la rédaction en
langue russe des RFI Camille grands
bonsoir bienvenue ancien secrétaire
général adjoint de l'OTAN spécialiste
défense au sein du sing tank de l'uepn
Council of foring relation enfin bonsoir
Mariana Perret benicike et bienvenue sur
ce plateau vous êtes journaliste
indépendante ukrainienne vous collaborer
notamment à la newsletter desk Russie je
vous l'ai dit deux documentaires ce soir
dans cette soirée spéciale nous vous
proposerons un documentaire inédit sur
les violences sexuelles commises par les
soldats russes mais d'abord le premier
film de la soirée
Ukraine des photographes dans la guerre
c'est un film de Julien Boyen avec
Frédéric de caussas crocodru par LCP et
Tony komity regardez
[Musique]
comme toujours comme tous les pays en
guerre il y a des gens qui fuient
[Applaudissements]
les gens sont ils sont stressés ils ont
perdu ils sont malheureux leur foot à
l'appareil photo sous le nez c'est quand
même
hein
l'empathie vis-à-vis de ces gens pas
envie de violer leur intimité et de
d'arriver comme
à moins que rien sous leur nez appuie
sur le bouton essayer de trouver une
image qui soit correcte qui soit
respectueuse et c'est ça le truc aussi
c'est quand tu photographies les gens
comme moi depuis 40 ans c'est
le mot qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est de
garder leur dignité donc
[Musique]
j'arrive au bout du quai au dernier
wagon il y a juste un homme qui est là
et cet homme qui dit au revoir à sa
famille et cette image qu'on voit
partout que tout le monde a fait de
quitter la main derrière Caro il y a une
petite main d'enfant derrière
et il se retourne il allait les larmes
au bord des yeux je le vois
éclaté et il se retourne et il me voit
et je suis tout seul quoi et il a besoin
de lâcher le morceau il me dit
je leur verrai peut-être jamais
donc ils sont là
ils sont là sur les rails et moi je
reste comme un con là au bout du quai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 24 février 2022 à 5h38 du matin la
Russie devl Vladimir Poutine
[Applaudissements]
depuis les Ukrainiens vivent sous un
déluge de feu
[Musique]
et nous sous un déluge d'images
plus de 2000 photographes couvre le
conflit aguerri ou novices il travaille
pour les grandes agences de presse les
quotidiens du monde entier où sont
indépendants tous documents de cette
guerre au plus près des bombardements et
des populations civiles
[Musique]
quand ça tombe du ciel on sait jamais ce
qui va tomber mais après moi je suis
prudent donc s'il y a un souci il faut
que je gère en plus cette femme qui nous
sert de fixeuse et collectrice qui n'a
jamais été pris dans ce genre de
d'endroit et de moments donc je lui on
reste calme et mieux aussi
Natalia est ukrainienne parlons anglais
russe connaît bien son pays mais elle
n'a jamais vécu dans la guerre
Éric lui c'est comment se comporter sur
ces terrains où tout peut basculer en
une seconde mais il ne connaît pas
l'Ukraine
lors de ce voyage vers l'inconnu leur
sécurité dépend de leur association
on va sur l'Est c'est un endroit qui est
très peu couvert on a réussi à faire
équipe avec les copains libaient et
c'est bien qu'on soit de bagnoles parce
que c'est plus sûr
juste là-bas et les rues sont prises
ORIAS et c'est
un petit 2 km quoi
nous on tourne en étant en parallèle à
eux en restant sur la droite
et donc on voit un petit peu commencé
dans la campagne aux alentours
tant qu'il y a des voitures qui arrivent
en face ou d'autres qui vont dans notre
sens
c'est bon signe
visco épouse
bonjour monsieur
Charles
[Applaudissements]
qu'ils ont détruit
il y a peu voilà et donc on peut pas
aller plus loin et ça aurait été bien
qu'on puisse faire trois photos ici
puisqu'on est venu jusque là
et voilà je me contente juste que de
faire une maison cramée parce qu'ils
veulent pas évidemment qu'on les fasse
en photo c'est normal c'est les
militaire classique
on va mettre les pendules à 0 c'est que
des photos sur des lignes de front c'est
très rare
c'est très très rare c'est parce qu'on
nous donne jamais la possibilité d'y
aller parce qu'évidemment c'est toujours
dérangeant d'avoir des témoins la guerre
est sale c'est qu'on se le dise une fois
pour toute
[Musique]
moi c'est la première guerre que je
couvre pratiquement où on a accès à
aucun des deux fronts enfin des deux
côtés
indépendants vraiment
sur ce fond
[Applaudissements]
alors je suis partie le 27 février
envoyé par le monde dans un premier
temps je suis parti en Roumanie de là je
suis allé en Moldavie ensuite je suis
allée en Hongrie et ensuite je suis à la
Kiev donc toujours pour le monde et là
j'ai passé trois semaines donc en
Ukraine entre Kiev carquilly et les
petits villages aux alentours de Kiev
qui avait été libéré
c'est mon premier vrai terrain de
conflit parce que même si j'ai travaillé
dans d'autres pays avant comme la Syrie
l'Irak la bande de Gaza ça a toujours
été sur les conséquences des conflits
c'était des situations qui étaient très
différentes tandis que là l'Ukraine
c'était la première fois que j'ai
assisté à un conflit en temps réel
d'où là j'étais ravi effectivement de
couvrir des aspects peut-être un peu
plus militaires un peu plus direct de la
guerre
après ça reste de la news donc c'est
quelque chose qui est très au jour le
jour où il y a quand même beaucoup de
jours qui se ressemblent tiens il y a eu
un bombardement on va aller sur les
lieux du bombardement tiens emballer
là-bas on va enfin voilà les
problématiques sont quand même assez
ressemblantes de jour en jour donc ça
m'a donné le goût parce qu'évidemment
c'est c'est fascinant et c'est
excessivement important de couvrir un
conflit comme ça en temps réel surtout
sur un événement qui est aussi
historique c'est quand même le premier
brouillon de l'histoire qu'on est en
train de faire comme on dit
on a fait un sujet pour le monde sur les
conséquences du conflit sur le port de
Constantin en Roumanie
[Musique]
on a fait la crise des réfugiés en
Moldavie par exemple la peur latente des
citoyens enfin des choses différentes
qui pour moi sont tout aussi importantes
vous parlez d'un conflit et je pense que
si j'avais fait six semaines de conflits
pure et dur je m'en serais un peu lassée
au bout d'un moment même si évidemment
il y a un peu ce côté addictif mais
parce qu'on a envie de on a en fait
envie de couvrir chaque seconde on a
l'impression que si on part on va louper
quelque chose d'énorme et moi si le
monde en fait n'est pas un peu forcé à
faire un break je serai peut-être rester
encore quelques semaines de plus sur
place
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les deux bombes à 5h du matin assez
forte puisque on a entendu ça de l'hôtel
et on est je dirais petite dizaine de
kilomètres quand même et donc la
première bombe bâtiment administratif
soit et là deuxième bombe donc
l'immeuble civil et rien qu'à voir les
dégâts je pense que il va y avoir au
moins une dizaine de morts facile donc
voilà totalement récompensé nous donc
pourquoi là est-ce que c'est une erreur
est-ce que c'est la politique de la
terreur
[Applaudissements]
depuis le début de toute façon nous tous
journalistes on est un peu paumés
on comprend pas la logique la tactique
de Poutine depuis le début
[Musique]
je suis parti en Ukraine au mois de
novembre tout d'abord pour une ONG qui
s'appelle people indeed qui venait en
aide aux gens dans le dos bas sur la
ligne de front c'est-à-dire entre les
zones
occupées par les séparatistes et les
zones ukrainiennes
donc j'ai profité de cette invitation
pour pour me familiariser avec avec
cette zone qui reprenait un tout petit
peu d'actualité avec le Poutine qui aime
assez troupes donc aux frontières et
généralement on est mis en commun d'une
fois qu'on est sur place pour X raisons
maintenant les médias je veux pas parler
tous les médias je veux pas jeter à
Pierre à tout le monde mais les médias
nous mettent en commande une fois qu'on
est sur place pour des histoires de
frais pour des histoires d'assurance ils
prennent plus autant de risques
financiers qui pouvaient prendre avant
donc c'est très difficile d'avoir une
commande en amont donc en effet quand on
part il faut se dire que les premiers
jours vont être
vierges de commandes donc ça veut dire
payer des hôtels ça veut dire payer
évidemment sa sécurité c'est-à-dire les
fixeur en tout cas la compréhension du
choses qui du lieu qui coûte très cher
surtout que en zone de conflit il les
prix montent beaucoup
très rapidement je me suis mis à
travailler pour Al Jazeera je me suis
mis j'ai travaillé avec Mediapart et
donc petit à petit on travaille c'est un
peu vu
j'y suis retourné ensuite trois semaines
pour l'Obs le Nouvel Obs et on a vécu la
fin du siège de Kiev et ensuite
on a été irpin bout de chat on a écouté
constaté avec comme beaucoup les
exactions qui avaient pu qu'il y avait
pu avoir eu lieu
[Musique]
Eric Bouvet est en Ukraine pour polka un
magazine spécialisé dans la photographie
il parcourt ce pays en guerre pour
retrouver un homme qui l'a déjà
photographié
c'était il y a 8 ans déjà pour polka sur
cette place la place maïdan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en 2014 sa photo de Vassil galamay fait
le tour du monde
grâce à elle va-t-il 27 ans alors
informaticien devient l'un des symboles
des révoltés de Maïga
comme lui des milliers de citoyens
ukrainiens vont occuper cette place nuit
et jour pendant 3 mois en plein cœur de
l'hiver
il finiront par renverser le président
de l'époque Victor yanukovitch opposant
obstiné à tout rapprochement avec
l'Union européenne
[Musique]
passer par dessus la barricade se lancer
à l'assaut de la police qui leur tirait
dessus à harmetal et je suis avoir
croisé d'autres qui redescendaient
complètement ensemble ou qu'on portait
sur des cils et ils sont arrivés
derrière le télérénaque on voit ici sur
les hauteurs là on s'est fait coincer en
première ligne et ça a été une boucherie
il y a eu fils dit 70 80 morts ce
jour-là je crois
au milieu de ce massacre lors d'un
assaut Éric Bouvet et la cible des tirs
croisés de la police et d'un sniper
pendant deux très longues heures il va
s'abriter derrière un monticule de terre
il photographie alors les révoltés de
maïdan tombant sous les balles les uns
après les autres
salut ils sont là
[Musique]
ça c'est ici
problème c'est que c'est des trappes
notre boulot tu sais pas comment ça va
se passer tu sais pas comment ça peut
tourner tu suis dégâts qui montent à
l'assaut bon ça tire tu fais attention
et puis à un moment paf ça s'arrête et
coincé des autres envoient tout ce
qu'ils ont et étaient coincé tu te
retrouves en première ligne comme un con
et tu savais pas alors oui bah oui tous
les autres journalistes sont restés en
bas
mais voilà en attendant on a ramené des
images et un doc
c'est très excitant c'est une vie
d'aventure souvent pas tout le temps
mais souvent
c'est sûr qu'on prenait c'est sûr voilà
ça c'est tout à fait normal mais il faut
qu'on puisse mesurer ses risques il faut
surtout que ces risques
aboutissent à quelque chose quand on les
prend je veux dire qu'il parution que
nos photos soient vus en tout cas que
notre message que notre témoignage
témoignage soit vu prendre des risques
juste pour prendre des risques pour
montrer que on fait la guerre et que
c'est super et que les balles sifflets
moi ça m'intéresse pas je pense que la
peur est nécessaire sur le terrain parce
que ça nous empêche de prendre des
risques inconscients je pense que sans
peur dans ce cas là on n'a pas de limite
et dans ce cas là on ne sait plus
attention à ce qu'on fait c'est là où on
peut prendre des risques inutiles
après évidemment trop de peur ça peut
également nous paralyser ça peut
également nous faire prendre les
mauvaises décisions la peur sur le
terrain au moment d'un bombardement ou
de avec des gens en armes ou énervés ou
d'un checkpoint qui se passe pas bien ou
je sais pas quoi pour moi c'est une peur
nécessaire et très saine qui évite la
nonchalance les petites blagues et
il renie et le sarcasme qui passe très
très mal sur un
alors c'est indéniable il y a un peu le
côté voilà adrénaline etc mais on est
quand même là-bas aussi pour défendre
quelque chose là on défend quand même
une invasion enfin on défend un pays qui
est en train de se faire envahir on
essaye de dénoncer des choses et je
pense que ça c'est un peu le plus gros
carburant également
moi en tout cas je sais que c'est ça qui
m'a poussé à faire ce métier à la base
c'est c'est j'ai ressenti un besoin en
fait de de dénoncer des choses de
documenter des choses enfin voilà ça
peut paraître un peu idéaliste mais
malgré tout je pense que l'essence
premier notre travail c'est ça aussi
quoi c'est dans ces conflits c'est dans
ces moments terribles que l'humanité se
révèle
et puis bon j'ai eu la chance d'être sur
le mur de Berlin quand il s'écroule je
serre la main demander là quand il sort
de prison enfin tous ces moments
historiques qui auraient pas rêvé de les
vivre je préfère être sur l'endroit où
se passe l'information plutôt que d'être
sur mon canapé à regarder ça à la télé
quelle vie
Eric vient d'avoir des nouvelles de
Vassil l'homme qu'il avait photographié
en 2014 plasmaidan
voici les dans un camp d'entraînement
aux alentours de le vive parmi d'autres
volontaires qui comme lui ont rejoint
les groupes de défense territoriales
[Musique]
à 35 ans voici il est à la tête d'une
unité paramédicale 17 volontaire non
trois femmes des médecins des infirmiers
une chirurgienne 30 ans de moyenne d'âge
ils ont tout abandonné pour venir se
battre sous ses ordres
très entreprenant assez directif donc si
son équipe ils sont prêts ils ont dit
ils sont entraînés ils ont tous les
équipements ils ont tout ce qu'il faut
aussi ils sont Fighter c'est comme ils
disent donc combattant donc ils font
aussi les apprentissages de savoir
comment se déplacer comment tirer
comment quand tu es avec d'autres
personnes on peut pas même faire
attention à ce que tu fais
pour l'instant voici les sons de leur
affectation en quelque part sur l'une
des lignes de front
pour Eric suivre facile serait
l'assurance de pouvoir couvrir la guerre
au plus près
[Musique]
mais quelques heures après s'être
rencontre l'unité de Vassil est appelée
en renfort en
urgence
dans la précipitation du départ
eric n'a pas obtenu l'autorisation de
les suivre
[Musique]
retour acquiesf qui à ce moment-là de la
guerre
est toujours sous la menace de
l'invasion des troupes russes
tu restes pas longtemps en statique au
milieu de la route
le pont reliant Irpina Kiev a été
détruit par les troupes ukrainiennes une
mesure préventive pour contrer l'avancée
des Russes qui ne sont qu'à quelques
kilomètres
[Musique]
pour les civils le franchissement de la
rivière reste le chemin le plus court
pour rejoindre la capitale
[Applaudissements]
il faisait un froid de canard et à
moitié et c'était évacuation elle a été
pour moi d'un choc émotionnel horrible
ces petits vieux dont certains étaient
grabataires d'autres qu'on était traînés
dans des couvertures c'était d'une
injustice
ignoble
[Applaudissements]
et le Pop est arrivé complètement
inattendu il se met au bord de la
rivière sur les planches avec le pont
derrière les gravats la fumée de
l'explosion derrière noir dans le ciel
j'ai juste appuyé sur le bouton
ça veut pas rentrer dans la boîte j'y
arrive pas
tiens voilà regarde le troupeau de
journaliste troupeau de photographe de
caméraman qu'on a rien à [__] de
j'ai pas appris à bosser comme ça moi
moi quand je vois quelque chose avant de
m'avancer je regarde si je vais pas
rentrer dans le champ de quelqu'un ça me
rend dingue
[Applaudissements]
tous ces trucs de barnum j'ai pas le
seul et barnum les
les événements où il y a la presse
internationale ça me rend fou
j'ai jamais aimé ces trucs pour
travailler c'est pour ça que j'étais
toujours fourré au fin fond de la
Tchétchénie ou de l'Afghanistan moi il y
a moins de monde parce que c'est plus
dur tu es pas à l'hôtel le soir et voilà
[Applaudissements]
des moments où je me suis abstenu de
faire des photos parce qu'il y avait par
exemple trop de photographes déjà sur
place par exemple des évacuations de
civils d'irpine où il y avait 10
photographes qui se jetaient sur la
première personne qui sortait de
l'ambulance qui sortait la pauvre dame
dont là j'ai eu un peu ce bon ce moment
de a un peu de déception par rapport à
mon métier et en même temps voilà on le
fait parce que parce que c'est important
de documenter tout ça et qu'on essaie
désespérément d'avoir des informations
et des choses à montrer c'est toujours
très délicat très compliqué de
travailler avec plein d'autres gens de
la presse et je sais que il y a une
image qui a été très décriée
dernièrement celle de lucha qui était de
contrechamps de tous ces journalistes
alignés qui avaient été convoqués par
des services comme l'État a emmené à
bout de chat et ils sont alignés devant
la fosse commune c'est sûr que je
comprends que ça puisse choquer quidam
qui n'imagine pas comment ça peut se
passer sur place moi je suis le premier
à dire je veux pas participer à ça et je
suis le premier à dire bah oui mais s'il
y a que comme ça qu'on peut le faire il
faut le faire
sans problème des dating aussi de la
part des journaux qui veulent telle
image telle mort dans la rue mais si on
dit qu'on a été dans tel petit village
qui est pas loin de lucha et les
rédactions ici vont dire
donc évidemment qu'il faut y passer
voilà et que que si on voit une rue avec
des morts on va vous pouvez regarder les
légendes des photos c'est un petit bout
de village à côté de bout de chat
[Musique]
malheureusement il y a un grand résumé
qui se fait
que les Ukrainiens ont très bien utilisé
mais il y avait plein il y avait plein
d'autres choses à faire et surtout on
est il y a plein d'autres choses à faire
en Ukraine
Guillaume Herbault va en Ukraine depuis
il a parcouru le pays en tous sens de
tchernobylo d'en bas
il faut que ça soit chargé pendant
20 ans de travail des milliers de photos
des milliers d'histoire de rencontre et
de visages un attachement viscéral à ce
pays
pourtant le 24 février jour de l'attaque
des Russes il n'a pas souhaité partir
pour couvrir le conflit
il y a déjà plus de 2000 photographes
sur le terrain je ne vois pas pourquoi
moi j'arriverai maintenant pourquoi je
rajouterai la présence d'un photographe
sur le terrain j'ai pensé d'abord à mes
amis et j'ai pensé qui était là-bas et
j'ai pensé aux personnes que j'ai
photographié et ça m'a mis dans un état
qui était pas bien pour travailler sans
exagérer je me réveillais je pleurais
quoi voilà et donc on peut pas
photographier avec des larmes devant les
yeux on doit photographier avec avec du
recul et pas mal de sang-froid et donc
c'était pas le moment quoi
[Applaudissements]
par contre les Noirs ça va c'est mieux
là on est à dans une ville qui s'appelle
abdiveka dans le Donbass c'est une ville
stratégique qui depuis 2014 je connais
des combats
quotidiens cet homme il habite à 100
mètres de la ligne de front la maison
elle a été touchée deux trois quatre
fois par des bombes et continuer à vivre
là il est tout seul il a jamais quitté
sa maison et la guerre est devenue son
quotidien
lui je l'ai vu deux fois je l'ai
rencontré en 2017
ça tirait on entendait les tirs en
arrière-plan il me racontait en fait
juste sa vie d'artiste il est sculpteur
et il est professeur il était professeur
de
d'arts plastiques et on a parlé à
dans un dans un environnement de guerre
c'est étrange parce que quand on va sur
un terrain pareil il y a un sentiment
d'éternité dans la photo mais les
moments de rencontre sont très rapides
mais il y a je crois que le lien de la
photographie est très fort quand il se
passe quelque chose dans une
photographie au moment de la prise de
vue le rapport qu'on peut avoir avec les
gens qu'on a photographié et bien ça
reste et c'est des gens qui vivent avec
nous
quand les chars russes entrent en
Ukraine les premières images à nous
parvenir sont celles filmées par de
simples citoyens
des images prises sur leur smartphone et
mis en ligne sur des réseaux sociaux
dorénavant dans l'histoire des conflits
ce ne sont plus les journalistes ni les
photographes professionnels qui
documentent en premier la guerre
évidemment qu'on est les deuxième
témoins et évidemment quand on a besoin
d'ailleurs des premières images qui
arrivent par les citoyens via leur
téléphone portable les premières images
les plus intéressantes en Ukraine là
pendant l'invasion russe c'était les
photos faits par les villageois devant
les chats russes qui bloquaient les
Russes c'était des images qu'on avait vu
nulle part il y avait pas de
photographes professionnels et il
fallait ces images par contre nous
on va rajouter
de la contextualisation aux images on va
jamais par exemple publier une image
sans une légende sans expliquer ce qu'on
montre de l'image on va forcément faire
un portrait mais en parlant la personne
en vérifiant les informations que la
personne nous dit si c'est pas nous qui
l'avons vu personnellement on est obligé
c'est quelqu'un qui te raconte tu es
obligé de trouver encore deux autres
personnes on le connaissent l'histoire
des trois personnes de regroupement de
trois sources d'informations différentes
pour être pour la valider voilà donc
c'est un job je le dis on regarde la
caméra ça veut dire toutes ces images en
direct ou je sais pas quoi sont sont à
plus qui vient un peu en amont qui est
plus en éclairer un petit peu la société
sur ce qui se passe mais le très grand
récit historique
en images c'est sera fait par des
photographes
[Musique]
la photo c'est pas un instant ce
quartier Bresson il a dit une connerie
dans sa vie c'est bien ça c'est un
moment une photo on est il y a l'avant
il y a la play il y a le hors champ il y
a tout le travail pour y arriver il y a
une vie pour arriver à cette photo
presse que il y a et pour moi une photo
qui est réussie c'est une photo dans
laquelle le spectateur va rentrer et va
pas être capable de sortir tout de suite
et trop rapidement pour X raisons par le
jeu de cadrage de champs de profondeur
de champ normalement il y a des flous et
il y a une information sur le premier
plan deuxième plan troisième plan le
premier plan peut-être flou et puis si
le premier plan est flou le spectateur
va devoir passer le premier plan pour
arriver derrière pour arriver à aller en
quête de l'information qui peut y avoir
plus loin donc on va un tout petit peu
maintenir les gens dans un temps un peu
plus long pour l'image la beauté je
pense de la photographie et du
photojournalisme c'est que par la beauté
et la force de nos images on peut
toucher en fait un plus grand nombre en
un coup d'oeil quelqu'un peut être
vraiment frappé par une situation on
peut attirer le regard d'un lecteur sur
un article parce que l'image est très
belle ou très forte parce qu'attention
il faut quand même faire des images qui
sont belles mais qui apportent de
l'information
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là nous sommes avec
des volontaires qui sont visiblement
en mèche avec le maire
et on a trouvé CEDIL pour qu'il nous
emmène alors que toute la presse est
coincée et nous font faire un petit tour
de ville monter le bombardement
[Applaudissements]
les gens qui restent ici ils s'organise
entre eux toujours la solidarité humaine
c'est extraordinaire
leur cuisine dehors de toute façon il y
a plus d'eau plus d'électricité de
chauffage et là voilà c'est une cuisine
communautaire dehors dans une cité comme
on en trouve chez nous dans nos
banlieues
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
extraordinaires de rencontres avec tous
ces gens qui s'organisent qui se qui se
sauvent les uns les autres
tendance à voir le bon côté de l'humain
[Musique]
je quitte cet endroit et je trouvais un
monsieur avec une blouse blanche et je
l'attrape et je lui mets vous faites
quoi vous êtes qui me dit je suis
médecin
là-bas sous l'hôpital noir total quoi je
m'éclaire avec le smartphone et il ouvre
une dernière porte
cave et là je vois ce vieux monsieur
sous ses couvertures qui a et je dis
mais pourquoi il a parce que il est
mourant parce que on peut rien en faire
on peut
et on se revoit on referme la porte et
je me dis bah voilà ce type après sa vie
alors quelle ville a eu
il va crever là comme un rat au fond de
son trou tout seul
là c'est toute l'humanité qui s'écroule
quoi c'est compliqué quand on se trouve
devant ses moments-là
[Musique]
j'ai toujours ce dilemme avec moi de me
dire mais appuie fait ses images quoi
souvent c'est très compliqué parce que
je suis tout retenu
quelque part je me suis conforté à me
censurer énormément dans cette vie de
photos journalistes parce que ça me
permettait aussi de garder cette dignité
des gens de ces scènes monstrueuses que
j'ai vu je me suis protégé parce que
j'ai pas de mal à me regarder le matin
dans la glace parce que j'ai toujours
justement fait attention aux gens le
seul souci c'est que
j'aurais pas dû faire ça j'aurais dû les
faire ces images qui étaient dures qui
étaient chocs entre guillemets si les
soldats américains quand ils sont
arrivés dans les camps en 45 en Pologne
en Allemagne si c'était dit la même
chose que moi non c'est horrible je sais
pas ces photos là et ben il y aurait pas
de témoignage aujourd'hui visuel et il y
aura encore des gens aujourd'hui pour
dire ça n'a pas existé
[Applaudissements]
évidemment c'est notre rôle de
photographe de montrer et de documenter
justement des atrocités
d'autant plus des crimes de guerre comme
là ce qui avait été commis envers les
civils aux alentours de Kiev
[Musique]
après je pense que c'est également notre
responsabilité justement de ne pas trop
en montrer ou de le faire avec pudeur
en tout cas moi je sais que la limite
que je me suis fixée d'emblée c'est
jamais les visages que ce soit un soldat
russe ou un Ukrainien ou un civil ou qui
que ce soit on ne montre pas le visage
et je pense qu'il y a deux types de
photographies qu'on va faire dans un
moment pareil c'est des photographies de
très près on va vraiment faire un
travail très minutieux presque mécanique
mais où on sait que ces images on va les
garder pour nous ça peut être des
documents de crimes de guerre
ça peut être des documents si un jour il
y a vraiment quelque chose à dénoncer ou
à prouver donc voilà donc par rapport
aux atrocités là non je fais des images
quoi qu'il en soit
[Musique]
donc il y a différentes manières de
faire ça peut être avec de la distance
en prenant peut-être des détails
[Musique]
je pense que la violence peut être
représentée aussi par des choses très
douces elle peut être représentée par un
portrait par un témoignage elle peut
être représentée par une suggestion et
c'est bien d'ailleurs de la suggérer de
la montrer par d'autres choses que la
violence parce que sinon on s'habitue à
la violence on a une accoutumance donc
faut montrer de plus en plus choquant
donc nos faut trouver d'autres manières
de montrer la violence aussi il faut
montrer c'est la violence de la guerre
et la violence de la guerre c'est pas
simplement quelqu'un de mort c'est
quelqu'un qui vivait et qui vivait dans
un le cadre dans lequel on évolue
aujourd'hui tous et en photo je pense
qu'en faisant un pas en arrière en
essayant de faire rentrer dedans la vie
normale en fait où l'arbre la maison le
le en fait ce qu'il y a pu se passer
avant on arrive à raconter des choses
qui sont bien plus dures que simplement
voilà un mort
ce qui est réellement choquant c'est
cette personne est allongée dans un
jardin dans son jardin il y a quelqu'un
qui a pris une balle dans la tête
[Musique]
j'ai vu beaucoup de morts j'ai découvert
pas mal de guerres et je sais pas du
tout comment gère toutes ces toutes ces
images et toutes ces ambiances
publiques une expérience que peut-être
un peu traumatisante au Yémen ou il y a
une petite fille qui avait reçu une
balle dans la tête et qui et qui avait
été laissé seul sur une un champ
opératoire enfin sur un brancard en
métal comme cette table qui avait une
dizaine d'années qui allait mourir mais
qui était pas morte et qui avait les
yeux grands ouverts et qui est en
hyperventilation et qui était toute
seule en fait dans une grande pièce
il y avait eu des bombardements et pour
X raisons était toute seule et je l'ai
pas prise en photo je l'ai pris la main
et et elle me regardait je sais pas s'il
me voyait etc et ça a dû ça a duré assez
longtemps jusqu'à ce que je croise le
regard de quelqu'un d'autre et que je
dise qu'on pouvait pas laisser un enfant
mourir seul en fait
[Applaudissements]
j'ai regretté de pas avoir fait de
photos juste le seul respect que je
pouvais lui montrer c'était de prendre
une photo pour essayer de transmettre
son regard et me montrer que c'était ça
la guerre de faire c'est un enfant qui a
une balle dans la tête la guerre
et il m'arrive souvent plusieurs mois
après de retomber sur des reportages
rééditeur reportage et me dire waouh
j'ai vu ça
j'ai vu un enfant comme ça ça me semble
complètement absurde enfin ça me
complètement irréaliste en fait donc
j'ai vraiment sur le moment une vraie
concentration une mise à distance je
suis pas du genre m'effondrer le soir du
tout ce qui veut pas dire que là en
Ukraine je
commence à faire des cauchemars je voilà
c'était moche quoi mais c'est peut-être
pour ça que je suis que j'y vais aussi
pour me rendre compte que la vie c'est
pas simplement
s'acheter des nouvelles baskets et puis
essayer de gagner plus de pognon et
avoir une nouvelle bagnole
[Musique]
du 16 mars au 29 avril les soirs du
lundi au vendredi le trafic est
interrompu sur le RER B entre Sanogo et
toile est trop Caléro voilà où ça nous
sert d'être revenu sur la semaine
dernière et ça va une communauté
[Musique]
tout ce que j'ai vécu tout ce que j'ai
vu comme Aurore je le sais c'est pas
effacé parce que je peux pas les effacer
mais ça me tournicote pas la tête parce
que sinon voilà je finis en hôpital
psychiatrique c'est une évidence donc
j'ai vraiment cette capacité j'ai fasse
[Applaudissements]
mais par contre effectivement j'ai des
petits flashs de temps en temps qui
arrive jour ou nuit mais je les ai fasse
tout de suite parce que je sais que
c'est pas possible je vois mes mes
enfants mourir comme 31 ans et 26 ans
aujourd'hui donc j'ai
reporté certainement toute cette
violence toutes ces horreurs je veux
dire porter sur eux qui me sont
évidemment les êtres les plus chers la
famille moi j'ai la chance c'est que
j'ai cette famille qui a été mon ciment
c'est évident que s'ils avaient pas été
là
j'aurais poussé plus loin le bouchon
et je serais allé trop loin donc soit je
serai plus là ou soit je suis allé
certainement devenu fou je pense que
possible
je me sens bien d'être à Paris en
famille je me dis que on a une chance
incroyable d'être dans un pays en paix
et puis je pense aux gens que j'ai
photographié
je pense aux douleurs
et puis je plonge dans mes photos et
c'est ça qui m'aide en fait à reprendre
la vie normale
et c'est compliqué parce que le en fait
j'ai plein d'images en tête mais
peut-être que la dernière image que j'ai
c'est un enfant
qui est dans sa chambre
qu'il partage avec sa mère et l'ambiance
est jonattre c'est très vêtu les lits
sont recouverts chaudes parce que le
chauffage est il y a pas beaucoup de
chauffage
et il a un téléphone portable entre les
mains la lumière éclaire un peu son
visage il est en train de jouer comme
n'importe quel gamin à un jeu vidéo
il vit à 500 mètres de la ligne de front
avant il vivait de l'autre côté du côté
séparatiste avec sa mère il était tout
petit quand sa mère a été enlevée par
les séparatifs et il a été enlevé avec
elle et il s'est retrouvé dans une cave
avec elle et elle a été tabassée devant
lui
elle a eu une simulation d'exécution
avec un revolver quand il va à l'école
ou quand il revient de l'école il a peur
d'avoir un débat perdu
et en même temps il continue à être un
enfant il est là avec son téléphone
portable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après 5 semaines en Ukraine
Eric Bouvet ramène à la rédaction de
polka une sélection d'une bonne centaine
de clichés
si pour ce premier voyage va-t-il lui a
glissé entre les doigts
Eric ne s'avoue pas vaincu
justement je vais t'annoncer quelque
chose que tu n'es pas au courant mais du
coup je repars oui mais ça c'est ce que
j'attendais de ta part
j'en attendais pas moins donc en ce
moment je sais pas je sais pas moi ils
m'ont dit que je l'ai eu je suis plus à
deux trois jours il m'a dit qu'il se
reposait et que que je sois pas pressé
je lui ai dit dans un jeu elle m'a dit
ouais certainement parfait
il y a des moments chocs comme ces types
qui sont accusés d'avoir être des
pilleurs qui se retrouvent
comment dire scotché à des poteaux par
des militaires et nu sache c'est cette
photo là je sais pas si on les on les je
pense pas d'ailleurs qu'on la publiera
moi je la sortirai parce que quelque
part c'est aussi dénoncer le fait que
voilà on sait bien il y a pas de guerre
propre tout est tout est sale
et nous notre rôle avec les photos
journalistes c'est de chaque photo qui
est sensible difficile déjà elle fait
débat autour de nous on en parle au
photographe et elle doit ensuite c'est
le lecteur qui va prendre leur laisser
lui le lecteur seul qui va être face à
cette image et c'est à nous de lui
mettre sur la table tous les éléments
nécessaires tangibles palpable et les
informations essentielles pour qu'ils
puissent accepter de la regarder et de
ne pas décrocher et tourner le magazine
ou le livre en fonction de son
exposition et finalement il passe à
autre chose et donc on a perdu le
lecteur si on perd le lecteur on a tout
perdu
[Musique]
une semaine plus tard
Eric repartait en Ukraine
à ses frais
il s'était fait la promesse de retrouver
son ami facile
et Éric Bouvet
est un homme à tenir parole
[Musique]
et bien voilà je retrouvais facile après
un mois d'attente donc plus de traces
des rues si nous avons traversé ces
villages
où ont été libérés ou les Russes sont
partis de même visiblement il y avait eu
des combats sur certains villages et
c'est extrêmement touchant de voir tous
ces gens sur le bord de la route faire
des signes les saluer les remercier
donner de la nourriture j'ai surnommé ça
un petit peu la route de la liberté
puisqu'on remonte vers le nord c'est
voilà bon ça rappelle des images d'antan
[Musique]
c'est historique quoi ça un monde qui va
changer je sais pas si les gens se
rendent compte mais ils vivent à
certainement peut-être le moment le plus
historique de leur vie aujourd'hui
[Musique]
et voilà donc pour ce premier film
coproduit par LCP et Tony cognity qui
nous fait prendre la mesure des
destructions commises par l'armée russe
on va dresser le bilan un an après
essayer de se projeter vers l'avenir
bonsoir Isabelle Lasserre que je
retrouve en plateau correspondant
diplomatique du Figaro nous sommes
toujours avec le général Dominique
trinquant ancien chef de la mission
militaire française à l'ONU elles Avid
d'algues spécialiste de la Russie et
d'actrice en chef en service du service
en langue russe des RFI camigrants
ancien secrétaire général adjoint de
l'OTAN et Mariana Pyrénées
indépendante elle est pour vous ma
première question Mariana ce qui frappe
c'est évidemment la résistance la
résilience l'endurance du peuple
ukrainien un an après il est forcément
endurci comment comment qualifier son
état d'esprit écoutez déjà je ne vous
cacherai pas que c'était ce documentaire
a été très frappant a été difficile de
revoir ces images qui ont été tournées
dans les premières semaines
forcément de l'invasion on le reconnaît
on ne reconnaît bien et c'est vrai que
c'est assez impressionnant de voir le
chemin qui a été parcouru
par toute la société ukrainienne par
l'Ukraine en tant que nation et parle le
monde par la même occasion personne ne
pouvait imaginer cela il y a un an et
pourtant l'Ukraine elle est toujours là
l'esprit combatif ou par ailleurs
illustre assez bien cet esprit
vif qui qui n'est cache rien de sa
douleur des difficultés que l'Ukraine
traverse mais qui préfère rester des
bouts faire se concentrer c'est
focaliser sur les choses qu'on peut
faire au jour le jour sur les choses que
chacun peut faire justement on parle
beaucoup de l'arrière la population à
l'arrière de la ligne de front c'est
tout un peuple qui participe à sa place
à sa mesure à l'effort de guerre il y a
plein d'initiatives aujourd'hui en
Ukraine à Kiev notamment exactement je
m'en souviens très bien quand les
frappes aériennes massives russes ont
commencé il y a quelques mois l'acte de
résistance c'était d'aller dans un
magasin de bricolage pour s'acheter de
des lampes de basse consommation ou
découper les de couper les
l'électroménager quand c'était démonté
par les autorités et c'est ça ce qui est
assez impressionnant ce que depuis le
début de la guerre chacun tout en chacun
essaye de faire ce qu'il peut à sa
manière et parfois l'acte des
résistances c'est tout simplement de
suivre les règles de bon sens ou les
consignes des autorités beaucoup de
crainiens par le russe elle est
proscrite cette langue aujourd'hui plus
personne ne veut la parler alors je
pense que c'est surtout là de la
deuxième option alors je ne vous
cacherai pas c'est parfois c'est une
découverte pour les experts occidentaux
mais quasiment tous les Ukrainiens sont
russophones et quasiment tous les
Ukrainiens sont ukrainophones tous
parlaient les deux langues parfaitement
et de manière assez fluide et c'est une
question tout simplement de
d'habitude ou de confort personnel
aujourd'hui le confort ne passe plus
alors le visage qui incarne cette
résistance et cette résilience c'est le
président volody mirzelenski qui n'est
jamais parti Isabelle Lasserre qui n'a
jamais faibli et qui galvanise son
peuple ou plutôt peut-être son peuple le
galvaniste vous l'avez rencontré on va
d'abord l'écouter c'était leur de la
première étape de sa tournée européenne
à Londres le 8 février au Parlement de
Westminster
[Applaudissements]
comment il est en vrai comme disent des
enfants en vrai il est très sympa c'est
cool il ressemble pas du tout un homme
politique classique on sent bien son sa
formation d'humoriste il a assez drôle
il est cash il est habillé simplement on
sent l'homme près de en fin de près de
près des Ukrainiens près de son peuple
on sent le on sent le côté très humain
du personnage et en même temps il est
vraiment charismatique
il a un leadership absolument incroyable
un sens de la formule aussi à la formule
bien sûr et moi j'avais déjà interviewé
quelques mois avant la guerre et ce qui
a changé c'est lui c'est que chez lui
c'est que il a désormais un
œil est grave on le sent quand même
inquiet c'est ça qui a changé les quand
on le comparateur chill certains font
cette comparaison c'est justifié ou ah
bah moi ça me paraît totalement
totalement justifiée il est resté
pour résister comme il défend son peuple
il incarne la résistance
ukrainienne il défend les valeurs de la
liberté contre celle de l'oppression ça
me paraît assez assez évident oui on
peut tout à fait faire la faire la
comparaison dans cette tournée
européenne il est allé aussi à Bruxelles
qui a migrants il a eu ses phrases très
importantes nous nous défendons mais
nous vous défendons à l'adresse des
Européens ça y est ce message là il est
compris par les Européens ça a pris un
peu de temps ça a pris un petit peu de
temps au départ les Européens ont
effectivement eu tendance à voir ce
conflit comme étant la réouverture d'un
conflit d'une dont ils entendaient
parler depuis 2014
ont presque peut-être espéré que ça ne
durerait pas longtemps d'une certaine
manière et que ça allait se calmer après
une offensive russe qui aurait pris un
ou deux bouts de territoire
supplémentaires mais au fil des mois on
est passé d'une guerre existentielle
pour les Ukrainiens
est devenu pour les Russes et qu'il est
aujourd'hui pour les Européens et ça
c'était très frappant dans le
l'engagement du président zellinski
devant le Parlement européen de voir à
quel point ces parlementaires européens
se sentaient en empathie dans leur
immense majorité avec le président
ukrainien existentiel pour les Européens
on peut dire ça vraiment on peut le dire
parce que ce qui se joue en Ukraine ça
va au-delà du crâne aujourd'hui
parce que c'est les valeurs de l'Europe
parce que si
il ne gagne pas une
issue du conflit qui soit la destruction
de l'Ukraine et ce qui était quand même
un petit peu l'objectif de guerre
affiché par Vladimir Poutine au début
c'est à dire à la fois sont
démantèlement territoriales et la
réduction de l'Ukraine à une sorte
d'état satellite croupion
on serait dans complètement autre chose
et c'est perçu par beaucoup de européens
comme étant à la fois une menace
potentielle qu'est-ce qui se passerait
demain mais aussi une menace très
directe sur les valeurs de l'Union
européenne faut jamais oublier que cette
guerre en réalité de maintenant presque
9 ans pour les Ukrainiens puisqu'elle a
bien commencé en 2014 a commencé parce
que des Ukrainiens manifestaient avec
des drapeaux européens sur les places de
Kiev Elsa Vidal comment on la regarde en
Russie cette image d'un Hélène qui
ovationnait par toute l'Europe par
toutes les capitales européennes ça
représente les deux choses que Poutine
exacte le plus finalement l'Ukraine et
l'Europe l'Ukraine et l'Occident alors
il y a des questions dans votre première
question d'une part effectivement il y a
une grande majorité de Russes peut-être
à peu près 60% qui sont globalement
acquis et convaincus par les
explications qui leur sont présentées
par le pouvoir actuel en Russie et qui
regarde cette union contre comme la
concrétisation d'une menace c'est à dire
qu'il y a un an quand Vladimir Poutine a
parlé d'une guerre de l'Occident globale
contre la Russie c'était évidemment faux
mais aujourd'hui un an après dans la
mesure où nous soutenons l'Ukraine nous
faisons front avec elle la prophétie qui
l'avait énoncé qui était mensongère et
quasiment réalisé si ce n'est que nous
ne faisons pas du tout la guerre à la
Russie et que nous prenons énormément de
précautions pour que cela n'arrive pas
maintenant est-ce que l'Europe et
l'Ukraine deux choses qu’abord Vladimir
Poutine peut-être à l'heure actuelle
mais je m'avancerai pas en fait sur ces
convictions parce que je pense que c'est
un homme qui est d'abord des intérêts et
pas du tout d'idéologie il fait feu de
tout bois il a plutôt géré une vision à
l'heure actuelle extrêmement investie de
l'Ukraine donc je dirais au contraire il
désire la contrôler à toute forme et
pour ce qui est de l'Europe actuellement
elle ne lui est pas utile elle est même
assez secondaire il entend avant tout se
positionner vis-à-vis des États-Unis et
fut un temps où avec Vladimir Poutine on
parlait éventuellement d'une d'un
rapprochement très significatif de la
Russie avec l'Union oui un temps voilà
qui semble bien lointain aujourd'hui
Dominique RACO je voudrais qu'on
s'attarde sur le terrain militaire on va
regarder une carte animée on va la
découvrir ensemble avant l'invasion
d'abord vous le voyez les Russes
détiennent la Crimée et puis les deux
provinces du Dombas lougans c'est donuts
le 24 février on l'a vu c'est l'invasion
on envoie les chars sur trois fronts
nord-est et le Sud et puis le pays
risque à ce moment-là d'être totalement
annexé et puis ensuite un an après
l'armée ukrainienne a repris le nord du
pays et une partie du Sud on l'a vu avec
les les couleurs bleu qui se sont
affichés comment vous juger les reprises
ukrainiennes et comment vous commentez
cette carte aujourd'hui alors ce qui est
très intéressant c'est d'abord de voir
que cette guerre à la mi-février
personne ne pensait que Poutine ferait
cette folie et lui il a fait un pari il
a pensé qu'en 3-4 jours il allait
pouvoir renverser le pouvoir et donc ne
pas faire la guerre faire pression et
puis grâce à la résistance
ukrainienne et singulièrement vous
l'avez souligné du président zinski faut
rappeler que juste après l'attaque les
Américains les Français leur lui
demandaient de partir et lui disait on
va vous accompagner dehors mais lui a
décidé de rester donc le peuple est
resté avec lui et
la Russie s'est trouvée devant un gros
problème c'est que la guerre qu'elle
n'avait pas préparé il allait falloir la
faire et elle l'a fait jusqu'à l'été en
progressant vous avez montré sur la
carte le sud l'est etc et puis deuxième
grande surprise ukrainienne à l'automne
une offensive ukrainienne Kerson car
kiff l'armée russe est enfoncée et là
tout le monde a été surpris en se disant
mais cette armée russe non seulement
elle n'arrive pas à vaincre l'Ukraine
mais peut-être que l'Ukraine pourrait la
vaincre ce qui était la nouveauté et
depuis la période dans laquelle nous
sommes en fin de période aujourd'hui
c'est la réorganisation de la Défense
russe et la mobilisation qui amène de
plus en plus de troupes
sur le front et qui grignote un petit
peu les positions
ukrainiennes mais toujours la très
grande parce qu'on a quand même
l'impression notamment avec barmod avec
solidark l'Ascendant c'est la Russie qui
la reprise
doit être tombé Wagner a déjà annoncé
deux ou trois fois fois qu'elle était
tombée elle n'est pas tombée donc ça
avance ça avance mais ça avance très
progressivement avec des pertes
absolument colossales du côté ukrainien
bien sûr mais surtout du côté russe on
pense qu'il y a 2 à 3 fois voir quatre
fois plus de pertes du côté russe et
donc ce qu'on attend aujourd'hui c'est
de voir si cette se rapporte de force va
évoluer et il y a une course contre la
montre les Russes voulant absolument
aller vite avant que l'armement
occidentale n'arrive on parle des chars
en particulier les munitions etc et puis
du côté
ukrainien cette contre la montre en
essayant d'avoir le plus rapidement
possible ces matériels pour que la
montée lente mais certaine des forces
russes ne soient plus pas produire ses
effets donc voilà où on en est
aujourd'hui un bras de fer un équilibre
difficile on ne lit pas dans la boule de
cristal on n'a pas où est il y a trois
divisions aux Russes qui ont été formées
en Biélorussie ont-elles déjà été
engagées complètement ou pas on ne le
sait y a-t-il une réserve ukrainienne
importante possible de la Russie dans
quoi les heures les jours le printemps
qui vient elles avaient Vidal elle a été
annoncée le début de la nouvelle
offensive russe il y a déjà plusieurs
jours après il semblerait qu'en tout cas
près de vous les dard elle était défaite
je toltenberg secrétaire général de
l'OTAN annonce qu'au contraire
l'Ukraine serait en position de
contre-attaquer au printemps je pense
qu'on est tous à un moment clé on se
rappelle l'année dernière où on n'avait
pas pris au sérieux les menaces pour
nombre d'entre nous d'invasion et qu'on
se doit de se préparer à cette nouvelle
offensive on ne peut pas l'exclure en
même temps c'est la stratégie de la
chair à canon là on a l'impression
Vladimir Poutine est prêt à envoyer des
centaines de milliers d'hommes ou par
même jusqu'à 500 000 hommes et on a
plusieurs milliers de tués par jour par
les Ukrainiens c'est quoi la fuite en
avance et la volonté de gagner même un
centime mètre carré de territoire coûte
que coûte il y a deux choses c'est à
dire que d'une part il y a effectivement
une mobilisation russe
Vladimir Poutine n'est pas en
communication partielle mais c'est
plutôt 300000 hommes qui ont été
mobilisés qui s'ajoutent aux vagues de
conscription normale donc on est
effectivement pas loin de 500 000 hommes
supplémentaires que la Russie entend
amené sur le front après il se pose
toute une série de questions est-ce que
ces hommes sont à peu près entraînés
équipés encadré et donc est-ce qu'ils
sont capables de passer réellement à
l'offensive ou est-ce qu'on est dans
cette logique qu'on a vu sur le front de
barmut de Shera Kanon de barrage
d'artillerie suivi de vague humaine qui
arrive à peine à progresser donc dans ce
qui va se jouer dans les dans les jours
et les semaines qui viennent c'est
effectivement la capacité de la Russie à
repasser réellement à l'offensive et
évidemment la capacité de l'Ukraine non
seulement à résister mais éventuellement
reprendre l'initiative au fil des
suivre les lumières zellenski de ne pas
vouloir lâcher barmut même si c'est très
difficile même si stratégiquement
peut-être que c'est impossible
Mariana juste après mais c'est vrai que
nous avons de de des interprétations de
cela qui peuvent être complémentaires
alors je pense que général Franco il
voulait simplement dire que c'est en
verrou un Véro supplémentaire il faut
jamais laisser faire sauter le verrou
sauf quand les villes stratégiques du
don-basse quand c'est là en sens n'est
pas si stratégique que ça backgroun bon
c'est un tout petit peu plus stratégique
que solidark quand même mais bon
c'était noble par contre
c'est quand même assez important il faut
comprendre que les soldats ucré le
militaires Ukrainiens sont sur leur sol
et vous avez vu dans tous les reportages
qu'il y a toujours des civils qui
restent dans les villes et qui veulent
être protégés on ne peut pas moralement
on ne peut pas les laisser tomber et par
ailleurs quand on regarde la propagande
russe notamment la propagande de russe à
dest des territoires occupés elle se
base sur les le fait sur les mensonges
que l'Ukraine aurait abandonné les
Ukrainiens elle-même qu'elle est soldats
s'étaient retirés par eux-mêmes il faut
savoir que dans les territoires occupés
il n'y a quasiment pas d'accès à
l'information libre même les moteurs de
recherche Google sont à son supprimer on
n'y a pas accès les gens ne peuvent
consommer que la propagande de russe et
c'est ce qu'elle dit donc c'est
extrêmement important pour le crâne pour
les Ukrainiens premièrement de défendre
tout ce qu'on peut défendre pour prouver
qu'on tient réellement qu'on défait en
droit chaque ukrainien et ensuite aussi
pour libérer les villes pour le camp sur
le plan militaire backmouth est un petit
peu comme ça l'était au printemps à
sévère de neige qui est ligiciank où
l'usure de l'armée russe a fait que au
moment où les Ukrainiens ont décidé de
se replier mais l'armée russe était
tellement usée qu'elle n'a pas pu
relancer son attaque et elle n'est pas
allée plus loin donc probablement que
backmouth c'est un peu la même chose il
y a des propositions qui sont préparées
sur les hauteurs au-dessus et au moment
où les Ukrainiens décideront de lâcher
parce que les indications que nous avons
aujourd'hui c'est qu'ils pourraient
lâcher ils auront suffisamment
usé l'armée russe pour qu'elle ne puisse
pas aller au-delà alors on va parler du
soutien militaire l'Europe l'Occident
l'OTAN livre des arbres on va voir s'il
faut aller encore plus loin mais
peut-être arrêtons-nous sur ces
livraisons d'armes est-ce qu'elles ne
sont pas arrivées trop tard est-ce qu'il
y a pas une forme d'aveuglement de
cécité y compris de l'OTAN des Européens
à ne pas avoir compris qu'il fallait le
faire ça très vite très tôt même
peut-être même encore avant le conflit
Isabelle Lasserre oui bah c'est certain
mais en fait au début de du conflit
l'Occident a cru que l'Ukraine allait
perdre assez rapidement donc l'Occident
ne s'est pas mobilisé ensuite il y a on
a eu à passer l'euphorie en fait de de
la fin de l'été de l'automne dernier au
nouvel impression que les Ukrain sur
leur lancée à les récupérer toutes
l'Ukraine il y a eu des pays au sein de
l'Europe qui ont vraiment freiné en fait
notamment la France et l'Allemagne pour
des questions d'opinion publique parce
qu'il y a pas assez de stocks militaire
parce que surtout on a on ne voulait pas
humilier la Russie et qu'on avait le
sentiment à Berlin et à Paris que des
négociations étaient encore possibles
avec l'avenir Poutine c'est-à-dire que
la nature du régime à mon avis n'a pas
été totalement totalement perçu enfin la
vraie nature du régime il y avait aussi
pour quelle raison une rue Sophie une
Russe officielle ancienne parmi les
élites françaises les élites politiques
les élites économiques et aussi les
élites militaires et c'est vrai que
cette russophilie qui s'appuie sur en
fait un
héritage le l'héritage d'un sentiment
américain encore très présent dans une
partie de la population et et et puis
aussi un espèce de d'héritage de du
gaullisme un gaullisme en fait mal
traduit parce que c'est un c'est un faux
héritage du Gaulois
il a toujours été un allié parfait
pendant les crises graves notamment en
1961 quel mot mais là tu en aveuglement
carrément oui c'est le terme qui me
convient en fait on a à l'exception
peut-être de la présidence Hollande on a
quasiment 30 ans d'immobilisme de la
position française envers et contre
toutes les guerres que le régime
devladimir Poutine a pu causer on en est
à la cinquième aujourd'hui ça peut se
comprendre quand on a cherché des alliés
et notamment auprès de la Russie dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme et le régime
de Vladimir Poutine a été très heureux
de pouvoir se rendre utile et c'est vrai
que on pouvait envisager un moment de
pouvoir neutraliser la Russie en
l’incorant beaucoup plus au corpus
européen et occidental mais c'est vrai
que sur 30 ans quand on se retourne on
voit très peu de décideurs français et
encore comme l'a dit isab
un petit budget mais c'est quand même
très impressionnant de voir que ce sont
la Lettonie l'Estonie Lituanie alors
effectivement la France arrive avec 0,5%
de son budget militaire si on prend
cette indicateur là si on ramène ça en
valeur absolue bien évidemment milliards
là ce sont les États-Unis le Royaume-Uni
la France qui vient avec les Pays-Bas
mais quand même ce chiffre si on regarde
le budget défense qu'est-ce qu'il
signifie est-ce que on donne assez
est-ce qu'on soutient assez et je parle
de la France et de l'Allemagne alors de
chaussée évidemment quand on a des pays
qui donnent près de 40% de leur budget
militaire on comprend bien que pour eux
[Musique]
est existentielle et que cette menace
est existentielle et que c'est leur
avenir aussi qui se joue en Ukraine dans
le cas de la France de l'Allemagne des
pays européens on a vu une sorte de
montée en puissance de l'assistance qui
a été lente à la fois pour des raisons
initialement
d'évaluation de la situation ça n'allait
pas durer longtemps il fallait
essentiellement donner les moyens
défensifs presque de guérilla en quelque
sorte pour aider les Ukrainiens
mauvaise évaluation de la situation
militaire sur le terrain et combiner
avec cette idée à mon sens assez absurde
qu'il fallait éviter une escalade mot
qui a été utilisé à maintes reprises
dans ce débat ou la cobelligérance comme
si aujourd'hui on traitait la Corée du
Nord ou l'Iran qui arme la Russie comme
des kobelligées on l'entend pas dans ce
sens là mais que quand il s'agit des
européens ou des Américains on craint la
cobelligérance et donc dans c'est un
contexte qui a amené à beaucoup de
débats beaucoup de réticences parfois
des débats fondés c'est-à-dire est-ce
qu'on a le temps de former les
Ukrainiens à telle ou tel type
d'équipement est-ce que telle ou
d'équipement est approprié pour le
théâtre crânien donc il peut y avoir des
hésitations et des débats y compris avec
les Ukrainiens logiques mais aussi
beaucoup de débats politiques dans nos
démocraties je vous adresse cette
question mais vous pouvez rebondir la
question maintenant c'est les airs et
les avions de combat
le Roy dit pourquoi pas alors
l'accompagnement progressif de tous ces
pays souvenons-nous simplement que les
pays que nous citions tout à l'heure
sont des pays qui ont été occupés par
l'Union soviétique qui ont connu des
déportations Lituanie qui ont connu des
assassinats catin donc qui sont marqués
dans leur chair donc si vous voulez
l'ours russe c'est pas un lointain
voisin comme pour nous donc ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point sur
l'armement effectivement ça a été très
progressif Isabelle Lasserre labyrte
trop lent très certainement aujourd'hui
on est à fond dans le soutien maintenant
dans le côté pratique et c'est le
militaire qui vous parle
l'artillerie solaire l'artillerie
essentielle et c'est ce qu'il faut
donner et les munitions en particulier
on en parlait à l'OTAN il y a pas
longtemps il y a un vrai sujet là ça y
est c'est parti les amis de guerre en
Europe pour fabriquer des munitions pour
ou des obus pour l'Ukraine c'est ça on
paye 25 ans de dividendes de la paix
nous avions des munitions pour nous
entraîner pas pour faire la guerre
et là on est obligé de mettre en place
des procédures qui n'existaient pas avec
même des règles européennes qui
interdisent la fabrication d'un certain
nombre de matériaux maintenant on est
arrivé au char donc c'est le maximum de
ce qu'on peut donner les avions
pardonnez-moi je suis pas un aviateur
mais il va falloir former des pilotes ça
va prendre un an à un an et demi pour
l'instant on a besoin de renforcer
l'Ukraine maintenant c'est à dire dans
les raisons pour laquelle on ne le fait
pas
l'Ukraine a demandé des avions il y a un
an et c'était clair que mais si on avait
commencé l'entraînement des pilotes il y
a un an peut-être qu'il serait entraîné
déjà vous aurez noté que vous aurez noté
quand même que il n'y a aucun avion
russe dans le ciel ukrainien les avions
ça sert à quoi à descendre d'autres
avions attirer loin ce que font les
Russes actuellement avec des missiles de
longue portée mais naturellement ça on
le veut pas pour pas tirer loin en
Russie et la troisième utilisation c'est
la plus au sol dans l'offensive mais il
y a une telle densité d'armes anti-A que
pratiquement on a absolument les villes
sont protégées c'est ça aujourd'hui mais
par des il y a tellement de missiles
mais bien sûr il y a beaucoup de
bombardements mais combien y a-t-il de
missiles qui arrivent au sol
proportionnellement à ce qui est envoyé
il y en a relativement peu je crois que
là-dessus il faut il faut reconnaître
une chose ukrainien c'est qu'ils font
disons des demandes de plus en plus
précises et motivées et justifiées donc
le fait d'ouvrir ce débat sur les avions
aujourd'hui en sachant que ça prendra
des mois jusqu'à un an ou un an et demi
de former des pilotes sur des avions qui
ne connaissent pas ça me paraît pas une
demande illégitime d'ouvrir cette
conversation aujourd'hui parce qu'on ne
sait pas à quoi ressemblera la guerre de
main et c'est pas aberrant de la part du
Royaume-Uni mais j'ai noté aussi que le
président Macron comme le premier
ministre néerlandais houteux n'ont rien
exclu donc d'avoir cette conversation on
peut la voir dans un moyen terme sachant
que une offensive se prépare
côté rue c'est ce que c'est
les priorités immédiates les priorités
immédiates c'est que les Ukrainiens ne
manquent pas de munitions pour leur
artillerie et les défenses solaires qui
leur permettent de contrer cette
offensive aérienne et de missile russe
permanentes et des moyens blindés qui
fassent que leur perte au sur la ligne
de France ou à limiter donc il faut
vraiment
bien penser tout ça mais ce qui est vrai
c'est que on doit penser la durée si on
prend ne serait-ce que la question des
chars qui est moins compliquée que celle
des avions c'est 1 à 2 mois
d'entraînement pour faire basculer des
tankistes Ukrainiens qui connaissent les
chars sur des blindés
occidentaux et sans doute un peu plus si
on veut même les entraîner techniquement
donc on est vraiment dans quelque chose
et il faut il faut prendre cette
question du temps en compte
alors je voudrais vous interroger
maintenant les avis d'elle pour qu'on
fasse un peu tous les aspects de ce
conflit sur la Russie
il y a rien à attendre de la société
russe elle est complètement cadenassée
par la propagande on soutient Poutine ou
on se tait c'est ça la Russie
aujourd'hui non c'est pas c'est pas
aussi simple que ça mais maintenant si
vous cherchez une réaction qui soit
apparentée est-ce qu'on pourrait
connaître en Europe ou même en Iran
effectivement vous risquez d'être déçu
ce qu'on voit en Russie alors d'abord
c'est un soutien quand même globalement
massif public à ce que les autorités
appellent une opération militaire
spéciale donc à la gare mais un soutien
qui est très différent selon les groupes
d'âge et les profils économiques des
gens qu'elle qu'on considère donc
globalement au-dessus de 40 ans il y a
un soutien assez massif en dessous de 40
ans et surtout chez les urbains il y a
une indifférence ou un rejet de la
politique maintenant traditionnellement
plutôt dans la société russe le refus ou
l'AB
se manifeste très différemment de chez
nous il se manifeste par des chaînes de
solidarité d'individus individus très
rarement par des actions collectives le
politique l'action politique en
elle-même est extrêmement déconsidérée
c'est aussi l'héritage de plus de
simplement si on considère là aussi
bolchevique et la Russie d'aujourd'hui
d'un peu plus de 100 ans d'autocratie et
de pouvoir extrêmement autoritaire donc
ça crée ça maintenant vous avez vu
peut-être l'interview du directeur de la
radio l'echo de Moscou dans le monde
ont-ils dit Alexa la haine est entrée au
sein de chaque famille évidemment étant
donné l'intégration des deux populations
et des deux territoires cette guerre
fait éclater en morceaux les familles
russes pour autant elles sont d'abord et
avant tout mobilisés si vous passez le
terme pour protéger les liens faire
échapper qui un fils qui un mari à
l'envoi à la guerre maintenant
j'aimerais dire qu'il y a un type de
d'opposition interne en Russie qui
généralement pas sous nos radars c'est à
dire c'est l'État qui résiste la
direction politique par exemple le parc
et russe a renvoyé chez eux plus de 9000
hommes qui avaient été mobilisés à tort
ça c'est les 9000 qu'ils ont réussi à
effectivement en renvoyer beaucoup plus
de dossiers et il y a des comités
également qui demandent les libérations
de nombreux appelés alors je voudrais
qu'on termine ce débat par l'issue
possible la question c'était la crème
peut-elle gagner cette guerre à quelles
conditions Ariana perab benescuk pour
vous reconquérir l'ensemble du
territoire
ukrainien y compris la Crimée c'est la
seule condition de la victoire alors
premièrement c'est la seule condition
depuis 9 ans parce que ça a été rappelé
que la guerre dure depuis 9 ans c'était
la seule enfin c'était la seule
condition depuis 9 ans tout le tous les
pays occidentaux mais quasiment tous les
pays du monde qui sont sur ces positions
là le respect de l'intégrité
territoriale de l'Ukraine et de sa
souveraineté mais heureusement parce que
si tel n'était pas le cas quel serait le
monde demain si on ne vise pas de
rétablir cet ordre mondial enfin de des
relations entre le monégie
toutes ces décennies de paix voilà donc
c'est souhaitable non seulement pour pas
pour le crâne mais surtout pour le monde
entier donc commençons déjà par cela
mais je voudrais quand même réformuler
la question sur est-ce que le crâne peut
gagner l'Ukraine n'a pas de chance le
crâne vague a gagné elle ne peut que
gagner on a hésiter la bonne question ça
devrait être comment nous pouvons le
titre ce que nous pouvons tous faire
pour aider l'Ukraine à gagner parce que
la question qui se pose aujourd'hui
c'est combien de temps encore quel
sacrifice encore pour les Ukrainiens
pour la société ukrainienne mais par
ailleurs comme elles a parlé pour la
société russe elle aussi donc
qu'est-ce que nous pouvons tous faire
pour que cette souffrance se termine le
plus vite possible alors on a en tête la
phrase d'Emmanuel Macron qui a un petit
peu évolué sémantiquement il dit
maintenant la Russie ne peut ni ne doit
ça veut dire quoi ça il est encore il
est passé depuis au stade au dessus et
maintenant en fait à l'Elysée on parle
de la nécessité d'une défaite russe donc
c'est totalement nouveau président ou
son entourage oui
effectivement victoire
ukrainienne donc effectivement ça a
changé maintenant qu'est-ce qui met dans
le mot victoire c'est là toute la
question et c'est vrai que c'est une
c'est une question parce que que la
victoire de l'Ukraine et la récupération
tous ces territoires y compris
l'exprimer sont indispensables on le
voit tous c'est absolument évident pour
l'ordre international pour la sécurité
de l'Europe pour absolument pour
absolument tout pour la cohésion et la
et la force de du monde occidental
simplement
l'Ukraine ne pourrait pas y arriver
toute seule et elle débute de guerre
elle dépend l'Europe de l'Occident et là
on est pas sûr que l'Occident tienne
jusqu'au bout Camille grand comment vous
voyez la suite est-ce que c'est une
guerre qui va durer sans liser d'abord
il faut remarquer que aucun des deux qui
gérant aujourd'hui n'a renoncé à
l'emporter militairement et donc ça ça
s'appelle plutôt une guerre qui va durer
puisque il n'y a pas d'appétit de
négociation pour les raisons qui ont été
rappelées du côté ukrainien mais il y en
a pas du tout du côté russe parce que
cette guerre peut s'arrêter demain par
le retrait des forces russes dukraine
c'est ça ça s'arrêterait immédiatement
donc on est dans quelque chose où on a
cette c'est pour ça que cette période
qui s'ouvre ce printemps va être
critique là-dessus tout est possible me
semble-t-il sur le terrain militaire
entre un effondrement de l'armée russe
parce que elle n'est pas encadrée
entraînée au bon niveau comme des
percées russes qui mettrai
l'Ukraine en vrai difficulté
c'est le soutien complet avec tout
l'armement et les munitions et la
logistique à l'Ukraine et la capacité de
l'armée ukrainienne comme elle nous l'a
démontré à l'automne de
comprendre l'armée russe et de monter
des opérations qui puissent défaire
l'armée russe du côté russe compte tenu
de la défaite qui vient d'être annoncée
de deux brigades qui ont été décimés sur
le front du Dombas j'ai l'impression
qu'elle n'a pas progressé tactiquement
et qui est elle n'a donc pas cette
capacité de percer souhaitons qu'avec
les moyens donnés par les Occidentaux à
l'Ukraine l'Ukraine et cette capacité
merci beaucoup on va s'arrêter là merci
infiniment d'être venu débattre pour ce
grand décryptage sur le bilan et un an
après l'entrée en guerre l'invasion
l'invasion russe en Ukraine on va à
s'arrêter à présent sur un autre aspect
du conflit les crimes de guerre et
notamment les crimes sexuels commis par
les soldats russes et on va voir qu'en
pleine guerre et bien la justice a déjà
commencé son travail
et on poursuit cette soirée événement
autour des 1 an de la guerre en Ukraine
la justice peut-elle passer dans un pays
en guerre c'est la question qu'on va se
poser ce soir avec mes invités dont les
deux réalisatrices du film que vous
allez découvrir tout de suite comment
enquêter quand l'urgence c'est la survie
comment rendre justice à des victimes
murées dans le silence crime sexuel de
guerre documenté l'horreur c'est un
document inédit pour LCP regardez
[Musique]
Galina a osé parler à visage découvert
parce qu'elle n'est plus si jeune parce
qu'elle n'a peut-être plus rien à perdre
et surtout au nom de tous les autres
[Musique]
car depuis le début de l'invasion russe
de nombreux cadeaux violences sexuelles
sont rapportés des femmes des hommes des
enfants
[Musique]
combien sont-ils impossible de donner
une estimation
[Musique]
ici à Kiev au bureau du procureur
général les dossiers arrivent au
compte-goutte
[Musique]
8 procureurs sont chargés depuis le mois
de septembre d'enquêter exclusivement
sur les crimes sexuels commis dans cette
guerre
une première dans un conflit en cours
mais pour l'instant
155 dossiers seulement sont instruits
dans le fracas des bombes
l'urgence n'est pas à la parole
la priorité des gens c'est de survivre
j'espère que dans le futur les gens
parleront plus facilement pour l'instant
ils ont surtout peur que les occupants
reviennent
comment enquêter lorsque le quotidien
des habitants est rythmé par les combats
comment repérer les victimes réduites au
silence sous le poids de la honte
et comment leur rendre justice
[Musique]
je vais mettre mon sac sous le vôtre oui
pas de souci la règle numéro 1 pour les
procureurs c'est désormais de quitter
leur bureau et de privilégier le terrain
à tour de rôle il sillonne les zones de
guerre en quête de témoignages
ce matin c'est au tour d'Olga
une longue route pour se rendre à isum
une ville occupée par les Russes pendant
presque 6 mois
si tu es dans la région de carquif à
l'est du pays elle est aujourd'hui à 70
km du front
la région de kerki fait bombarder
presque tous les jours je n'ai pas peur
nos vies dépendent de la volonté divine
chacun sa destinée et moi c'est ma
responsabilité et mon travail d'aller
aider les gens
j'en tire une certaine fierté
pour vous de venir ici
les gens se méfient des autorités
judiciaires alors nous venons au contact
des victimes pour qu'il ne nous
craignent pas pour qu'il n'ait pas peur
de témoigner
et témoignages sont très importants pour
notre travail
la ville porte les stigmates des combats
les rues sont fuis il y a seulement 5
mois un passé à vif Colga va tenter de
sonder
sa mission commence dans le bureau du
maire
je suis procureur ma fonction c'est
d'enquêter sur les violences sexuelles
commises au cours de cette guerre
pour vous vous êtes peut-être déjà au
courant mais ici on a déjà recensé
beaucoup de cas de violences sexuelles
sur les femmes
entrer
voici Nadia directrice du service social
de la ville d'isium avec Nadia patrina
on prend toutes ces histoires très à
coeur
ce n'est pas possible de faire autrement
vous avez plus de contacts que nous avec
les habitants les gens vous parlent plus
facilement qu'à nous si vous entendez
parler d'un cas qui concerne notre
domaine faites-nous signe et on viendra
me prier
les gens vont-ils se confier à un
procureur qu'il ne connaissent pas Olga
veut rassuré
a besoin de temps avant de parler quand
elle se sentira vraiment prête alors à
ce moment-là nous reviendrons la voir et
nous irons au fond des choses avec elle
merci au revoir
[Musique]
pour se faire connaître les procureurs
ont fait imprimer des brochures
d'information
et le meilleur endroit pour trouver du
monde c'est au point d'aide humanitaire
notre caméra reste en retrait
bureau du procureur général désolé de
vous déranger pour les femmes qui ont
été victimes de violences sexuelles
voilà des brochures vous y trouverez
toutes les informations pour obtenir de
l'aide et là il y a un numéro d'urgence
dans les brochures roses bonjour bureau
du procureur général
Holga en profite pour poser des
questions au hasard des rencontres
de civil
nous sommes restés tout le temps chez
nous ça tirait de partout les bombes
voler au-dessus de nos têtes
Olga le sait ce sont les femmes qui
parleront plus facilement
les hommes eux sont plus fermés même
s'ils ont été victimes de violence
sexuelles il ne le diront jamais comme
ça dans la rue à une étrangère
[Musique]
ce jour là Olga ne recueillera ni
information ni indice mais à la semé des
graines elle reviendra ici si des
victimes se décident à parler et à se
faire aider
de temps que représentant judiciaire
notre but bien sûr c'est que la victime
obtienne toute l'aide psychologique et
morale nécessaire il faut aussi que les
criminels soient punis que la victime
puisse avoir la satisfaction de savoir
que son bourreau a été puni en
distribuant ses brochures on veut aussi
montrer aux gens que la société ne les a
pas abandonnés
ne pas abandonner les victimes c'est
l'objectif de cette unité spéciale
des victimes qui se sont trop longtemps
et trop souvent senti livrés à
elles-mêmes
dans l'ouest de l'Ukraine à Poliana loin
des zones de combat
Galina celle qui a porté plainte vient
de parcourir 700 km pour retrouver les
femmes de l'association Sénat
le viol qu'elle a subi elle leur a déjà
raconté aujourd'hui elle est venue
parler de la suite quand son village a
été libéré elle a demandé une aide
médicale pour ses douleurs au ventre
mauvaise surprise au cabinet du médecin
ce sont des hommes du SBU les services
de renseignement Ukrainiens qui se sont
occupés d'elle
un de ces hommes m'a dit de me
déshabiller pendant que la gynécologue
restait loin dans un coin de la pièce
quand j'ai écarté les jambes il a dit ah
oui le cas est très clair là
et l'autre a fait des photos
la docteur a tout vu mais elle n'a pas
bougé
je lui ai dit j'ai besoin d'un
traitement j'ai demandé tous les tests
possibles pour le sida les maladies
sexuellement transmissibles il m'avait
fait ça dans de telles conditions
la gynécologue m'a dit qu'elle ne
pouvait pas le faire à moins que je paye
du coup j'ai emprunté de l'argent à mon
voisin
merci beaucoup d'avoir partagé ton
histoire avec nous tu mets en évidence
un vrai problème
comment le gouvernement a pu
m'abandonner comme ça
à partir de maintenant tout va aller
mieux
oui ça va
j'ai passé tellement de temps toute
seule et maintenant je suis très
contente de vous avoir les filles
toutes ces femmes qui la soutiennent ont
elles aussi subi des violences sexuelles
quelques années avant gallina dès 2014
dans la région du Dombas elles ont
ensuite créé cette association pour
s'épauler
huit ans après elles ont enfin le
sentiment que les choses commencent un
peu à bouger
ouvertement
et personne ne comprenait vraiment notre
souffrance
a commencé j'ai l'impression que le
monde entier et les autorités
ukrainiennes commencent enfin à nous
croire à croire ce qui nous est arrivé
avec ce qu'elle a vécu Irina est
persuadée qu'elle trouvera les mots pour
libérer la parole mieux qu'un procureur
ou qu'un policier
alors depuis le printemps elle se rend
dans les territoires libérés en quête de
témoignage
accompagné de son mari elle prend
aujourd'hui la direction de Kerson une
ville située en pleine zone de guerre
sur la ligne de front au sud du pays
ah tiens il y a une station-service là
elle est complètement détruite
c'est comme quand on est allé à bout de
chat
Irina et son mari n'arrive pas à les
mains vides
puisqu'il est si difficile d'obtenir des
tests eux vont les mettre à disposition
des victimes
comme c'est absolument nécessaire pour
les femmes aujourd'hui
elles ne disent rien
elle ne s'adresse même pas un médecin
qui est dramatique si jamais elles ont
été infectées
de convaincue victime des séparatistes
prorus en 2014 elle s'occupe désormais à
plein temps de son association
son combat est une revanche sur son
histoire personnelle
je suis bien viol avec un sac sur la
tête
et
après
je ne pourrais jamais
identifier ce type
ne sera jamais puni s'il est encore
vivant et moi
avec le temps Irina s'est constitué un
réseau d'informateurs on lui a parlé
d'une femme qui pourrait connaître des
victimes
bonjour
il est mignon ce petit bout de chou tout
en bleu
elle vit ici avec son mari et un
orphelin de guerre qu'ils ont adopté
je viens vous voir vous parce que vous
circulez dans la région que vous parlez
avec les gens du coin vous avez
certainement des contacts vous avez dû
entendre des choses je voudrais vous
demander oui je comprends il s'est passé
plein de choses dans le coin moi
ces personnes là on doit les aider
la conversation prend alors une tournure
inattendue
ça m'est arrivé à moi
mon mari ne veut pas que je le raconte
mais
on a été dénoncé on a été dénoncé pour
avoir aidé l'armée ukrainienne
lorsqu'ils sont arrivés j'ai passé deux
jours dans leur sous-sol au début ils
m'ont électrocuté avec un truc comme ça
je n'ai pas pu bien voir parce que ma
tête était couverte puis je suis tombé
dans les pommes ils m'ont violé à
plusieurs reprises ils ont fini par me
libérer et là ils ont même voulu m'aider
oui pour se déculpabiliser c'est ça
c'est mon histoire Irina découvre
qu'elle a en face d'elle une victime
elle connaît la procédure mais dites moi
vous en avez parlé au procureur sans que
votre mari ne soit au courant donc
seulement au SBO seulement au service de
renseignement c'est bien mais c'est le
bureau du procureur qui collecte les
témoignages c'est lui remonte les
dossiers
en fait je ne suis pas allé voir le
procureur parce que vous savez mon mari
souffre beaucoup de ne pas avoir pu me
protéger c'est aussi pour ça que je ne
voulais pas qu'il assiste à cette
conversation
alors regardez ça c'est pour vous de ma
part je vais vous laisser aussi ces
boîtes même si la date d'expiration
approche ce sont des auto tests
Irina reviendra le lendemain elle veut
persuader la victime de parler au
procureurs
convaincre les femmes de porter plainte
ne suffit pas il faut accumuler les
indices les preuves lors des conflits
passés trop de violences sexuelles sont
restées impunies faute d'enquête
immédiate
dans les locaux en état de siège du
bureau du procureur de Kiev une course
contre la montre s'engage
la chef de l'unité spéciale Irina
didenko doit avec ses équipes aller vite
ne rien laisser au
[Musique]
hasarder des éléments différents dans
certains cas on a pu saisir les papiers
les documents sur place on peut aussi
retrouver les traces d'ADN on a même
mené des examens médicaux légaux qui ont
confirmé ces faits de violence sexuelles
on tente de récupérer un maximum de
preuves et pour ça il y a tout un
protocole à suivre on essaie aussi de
comprendre comment ces criminels de
guerre se sont déplacés où ils sont
allés s'ils ont commis des crimes dans
plusieurs maisons parce qu'il arrive
souvent qu'il passe de maison en maison
à la recherche de femmes
enquêter pour nourrir de futurs procès
et peut-être envisagé un jour la
création d'un tribunal spécial
pour cela dossier après dossier les
procureurs tentent de remonter la chaîne
des responsabilités un travail difficile
[Musique]
pour s'orienter dans les subtilités du
droit il y a a pris un avocat
il a 22 ans et en avril dernier il a été
violé un checkpoint par des soldats
russes
depuis ce traumatisme il a tenté de se
suicider à plusieurs reprises
[Musique]
quel était son grade a-t-il donné ou
reçu des ordres
de la réponse à ces questions dépend
toute la procédure judiciaire lancée par
son avocat
s
ils pourront être traduits à la haine
devant la justice internationale
et les autres ceux qui ont obéi à cet
ordre iront devant les tribunaux
Ukrainiens
il est possible que certains d'entre eux
soient aujourd'hui dans nos prisons
c'est pour ça qu'on doit travailler
ensemble pour
identifier ces gens aussi vite que
possible
je suis sûr que la Cour pénale
internationale de la haine restera pas
silencieuse
il n'y avait pas de délai de
prescription pour ces cas
non il n'y a pas de délai même s'il est
coupable sont identifiés et retrouvés
dans très longtemps même dans 10 ans ce
que je ne souhaite pas il ne pourront
pas échapper à leur responsabilité
car c'est un crime de guerre
et un crime de guerre n'a pas de date de
prescription c'est bon à entendre
l'avocat d'Ilia a lancé une double
procédure auprès du procureur de Kiev et
devant la Cour pénale internationale
en Ukraine la CPI a ouvert une enquête
en mars dernier crime de guerre crimes
contre l'humanité génocide c'est elle
qui déterminera la qualification des
crimes sexuels
tout le monde est prêt
pour étayer les dossiers et aider à
qualifier ses crimes Anna et son équipe
d'experts internationaux se sont
installés à Kiev il seconde les
procureurs dans leurs enquêtes
avec eux ils cherchent à prouver le côté
systématique de ces viols
je travaille en ce moment sur un cas de
violence sexuelle commise sur une femme
dans la région de Kiev dans un village
qui a été occupé
et pour moi il y a un point intéressant
l'auteur présumait appartiendrait à la
même unité qu'un des types de ton
dossier de Nice je pense qu'il faut le
signaler au procureur il y a des
éléments de systématisme
d'ailleurs les soldats russes quand ils
occupaient ce village il cherchait des
signes d'appartenance à la nation
ukrainienne
pourraient indiquer une certaine
intention
ça pourrait bien confirmer cette théorie
que nous sommes dans un crime
systématique et pas dans des incidents
aléatoires
155 dossiers c'est encore trop peu pour
vraiment identifier et confirmer des
éléments de systématisme mais quand on
regarde la situation région par région
on commence à voir que dans certaines
zones il y a le même type de pratique
criminelles qui se répètent et comment
certains cas sont très similaires
c'est violent sexuel font-elles partie
d'une stratégie sont-elles utilisées
comme une arme de guerre
pour l'avocat il y a forcément une
responsabilité des autorités russes
[Musique]
je suis persuadé qu'il n'y a pas d'ordre
écrit qui dirait violer les citoyens du
crayon
ce serait ridicule mais en fait c'est en
eux dans leur tête
et les autorités au plus haut niveau
n'ont fait que mettre de l'huile sur le
feu en disant que l'Ukraine n'est pas un
état et qu'ici il y a des mauvaises
personnes qui ne méritent pas de voir
leurs droits respectés
malheureusement sur l'intégralité du
territoire ukrainien un schéma se
dessine partout ou des militaires russes
étaient présents il y a eu des crimes à
caractère sexuel
personne n'est protégée ni les femmes ni
les hommes ni les enfants cela touche
tous les civils de 4 à 82 ans
pour nous c'est crimes sexuels ne sont
pas des cas isolés c'est une manœuvre
systématique d'intimidation et
d'extermination de la population locale
en Ukraine trois procès ont déjà eu lieu
seulement par contre humains
pour rendre justice aux victimes
procureur experts et associations vont
continuer leur long travail d'enquête
voilà donc pour ce document inédit LCP
que vous avez réalisé marine Courtat
bonsoir et bonsoir il en est chaude on
va revenir largement sur la manière dont
vous avez pu suivre cette procureur
aciev sur la manière dont vous avez
recueilli ces témoignages bonsoir Céline
Bardet ravi de vous accueillir vous êtes
juriste international spécialisé sur les
crimes de guerre sur les crimes
internationaux vous êtes la fondatrice
de l'ONG wear notens of War sur les
crimes sexuels dans les conflits bonsoir
Véronique naomgrapp bonsoir et bienvenue
anthropologue et ethnologue vous avez
beaucoup travaillé sur ces questions de
crime sexuels Mariana Perret bene Sike
est restée avec nous bonsoir rebonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes journaliste
ukrainienne indépendante alors je me
tourne d'abord vers vous deux Ilona
Schulz c'est rare je le disais
d'entendre des témoignages comme comme
cela
c'est c'est difficile de porter plainte
évidemment dans un pays en guerre c'est
aussi très difficile d'accepter une
caméra vous avez déjà travaillé je crois
sur ces questions de crime sexuelles
comment on arrive à conflaincre ces
femmes cet homme qui témoigne non
seulement de le faire mais avec le
regard d'une caméra
déjà je crois que effectivement le fait
que on ait travaillé marin et moi en
Ukraine depuis longtemps et notamment si
sur les crimes sexuels depuis 2016
on a noué des contacts forcément à des
interlocuteurs sur place
voilà qui facilite les choses et puis et
la connaissance de ce sujet de ce sujet
là c'est la justice
ukrainienne et notamment cette procureur
qui vous a amené assez ces femmes là pas
forcément à ces personnes là mais de
manière générale que ce soit au niveau
des associations des avocats qui
travaillent sur ce sujet depuis
longtemps parce que comme on l'a vu
c'est des crimes des homosexuel ne date
pas que de l'invasion à grande échelle
donc il y a déjà ça et puis
après c'est aussi une une posture en
fait à avoir je pense quand on rencontre
ces personnes là ne jamais enfin faire
comprendre que on n'est pas là pour les
forcer à obtenir absolument à un
témoignage on est là pour raconter
l'histoire qui veulent bien nous nous
confier dans une posture respectueuse et
sans jamais
forcer le questionnement il y a une
écoute et un regard particulier on le
voit bien dans dans le film marine
Courtade il y a cette scène incroyable
ou Irina cette femme ukrainienne qui a
été victime d'un viol avant cette guerre
là
sillonne le pays avec son association et
réalise à la faveur d'une conversation
avec une femme dans un village qu'elle a
en face d'elle une victime une victime
de viol cette scène là par exemple
vous saviez ce qu'elle allait se passer
en la tournant non alors ça ça a été une
vraie surprise pour le coup parce que
nous on partait avec Irina dans ce
village là en pensant qu'on allait
rencontrer une témoin qui allait
peut-être nous amener vers d'autres
victimes et qui allait nous raconter ce
qui s'était passé dans ce village là et
tout d'un coup elle se met à raconter
elle éloigne son mari nous en plus on
parle pas la langue ou on travaille dans
ce pays depuis longtemps mais on n'a pas
appris cette langue et donc on filme la
scène d'Irina avec cette femme et puis
on a notre traductrice avec nous qui
tout d'un coup nous dit ah mais là je
crois qu'il se passe quelque chose et
donc nous à ce moment là on se demande
aussi qu'est-ce qu'on fait nous en tant
que journaliste alors que la caméra est
déjà
enclenché filmé et donc du coup on
laisse les choses se passer et puis
après on a discuté avec cette femme et
on a voilà un peu expliqué ce qu'on
faisait pourquoi on était là et discuter
aussi de son de la question de son
anonymat parce que c'était une vraie
question qui se posait
qui se pose d'ailleurs pour toutes les
victimes qu'on a rencontrées je précise
que les lieux ne sont pas nommés un deux
dans le film et que évidemment elles ont
donné leur accord et c'est leur volonté
de de témoigner à visage découvert
encore une question et puis je fais
circuler la parole ce qui se dégage du
film c'est à la fois que c'est assez
précurseur c'est assez fort de voir une
justice
en acte dans un état en guerre et en
même temps elle a un côté tellement
artisanal et tellement fragile est-ce
que c'est l'état d'esprit des procureurs
des magistrats ils sont conscients de ça
eux ils sont extrêmement motivés de de
faire avancer la justice de faire
avancer les enquêtes etc cette unité
spéciale elle a été créée en septembre
et en fait depuis qu'ils ont créé cette
unité ils ont vu aussi les limites dans
les dans lesquelles ils se sont
retrouvés notamment sur la question la
protection des victimes et ça c'est des
choses sur lesquelles ils ont avancé
petit à petit ils ont modifié ils ne
cessent en fait de modifier
fonctionnement en fonction des retours
des victimes en fonction de ce qui se
passe aussi sur place parce que la ligne
de front ne cesse de bouger et tout
bouge donc en fait voilà ils sont dans
une adaptation permanente avec les
limites que comporte d'enquêter dans un
pays qui est dans le conflit continu
c'est une Bardet comment vous vous
réagissez à ce film évidemment des
témoignages vous vous en avez recueilli
entendu
au fond il y a cette dimension
incroyable d'une d'une justice en acte
en temps de guerre est-ce qu'elle elle
va trop vite est-ce que ça vous inquiète
ou est-ce que ça vous réjouit
non j'ai envie de dire ni l'un ni
l'autre c'est à dire que enfin c'est
quand même ça m'inquiète si un peu et
puis après il y a quelque chose qu'il
faut comprendre c'est qu'il y a deux il
y a deux étapes il y a la question de la
documentation d'aller recueillir des
témoignages c'est à dire collecter les
éléments de preuve et le processus de
justice qui déjà sont deux choses
différentes et en effet l'Ukraine a mis
en place un processus de justice au
niveau national qui est un peu ralenti
là c'est inédit alors ça c'est payant
c'est totalement inédit surtout surtout
à un niveau national et ça a posé
beaucoup de questions parce que je pense
que ces procès n'ont pas été même avec
la meilleure volonté qui soit parce
qu'il y a une volonté laissée procès là
n'ont pas été menées je pense dans les
standards dans lesquels ils auraient dû
être menés donc mais c'est très
compliqué en fait de faire ça en plein
voilà en plein conflit et puis l'autre
question parce que est-ce que le fait de
le faire en plein conflit on voit bien
qu'il y a une question de justice il y a
une question politique aussi on va en
parler mais
le principal le message l'impunité pour
les crimes de guerre c'est fini c'est ça
que ça renvoie aussi comme comme message
oui à dire que c'est maintenant qu'ils
sont commis les crimes et donc c'est
maintenant qu'il faut avoir les preuves
oui Non Non mais encore une fois avoir
les preuves c'est une chose mais ça ça a
été l'oppositionnement des élanski c'est
un ski il a dit ah on va se défendre on
va résister et deux on répondra avec le
droit donc oui c'est ce qu'ils font
maintenant il n'empêche que il faut
avoir des des auteurs de crimes donc il
faut les arrêter il faut qu'il soit sur
le territoire et on voit que c'est pas
toujours le cas et ensuite il faut
respecter un minimum de standard aussi
parce que son écrits complexes à
poursuivre donc c'est pour ça que c'est
important la justice elle a besoin de
temps que ça nous plaise ou non la
justice elle a besoin de temps on va y
revenir à cette question centrale du
temps Véronique naomgrap comment vous
vous réagissez à ce film il y a un
travail de réparation aussi qui est à
l'oeuvre avec ses premiers témoignages
on est au-delà peut-être même de la
question de la justice parce que je
trouve formidable c'est quand une des
personnes dit je veux que ça n'arrive
plus jamais sur la planète entière
c'est-à-dire que oui la justice est
fragile oui elle est lente oui peut-être
on sera tous mort avant que le premier
criminel soit traîné derrière les
barreaux mais le rêve de justice était
énorme le plus jamais ça nous on le
traîne depuis tout le temps je crois
tout mais depuis 45 donc au moins au
moins mais je crois qu'après chaque
crime infâme il y a cette idée plus
jamais ça et sur la planète entière donc
il y a cette question du rêve de justice
et qui est impossible à effacer de la
même aussi important que la justice
elle-même exactement
l'autre chose aussi qui a été terrible
avec ses crimes donc toute torture est
un viol tout viol est une torture dans
ces conditions et donc tout viole est
une torture dans toutes les conditions
donc si vous voulez il faut donner le
mot la dignité du mot torture et ce qui
a particulier c'est que contrairement
aux crimes non sexuel
sexuels ont des un effet de soudure qui
salit immédiatement la victime même une
victime qui n'est pas dans une idée très
traditionnelle dans les dans les
sociétés très traditionnelles où la
définition de la femme son honneur tient
sa sexualité elle est foutue tout
l'Ancien Régime les viols sont suivis de
punitions et d'infamides d'infamie
sociale de la femme violée ou la très
jeune fille violée et même encore les
crimes d'honneur peuvent un père peut
tuer sa fille de 16 ans parce qu'elle a
été violée et c'est elle qui porte la
souillure sur l'ensemble de la famille
mais il n'y a pas que ça même dans les
sociétés très évoluées et on voit la
dame qui dit je le fais parce que je
suis un peu âgé je le fais pour parler
parce que moi je parle il y a une honte
c'est-à-dire ce sont des crimes les
crimes de soudure font basculer la
salissure dans le corps même de la
victime et cette honte est une des
choses qui portent vraiment qui empêche
et qui qui empêche pour ces crimes
infernaux que le travail classique de la
comme dans les romans policiers puissent
être fait normalement Mariana Perret la
messieurs le déclencheur de la volonté
des Hélène ski de faire travailler la
justice et le plus vite possible ces
bouts de chat c'est bout de chats et les
et les possibles charniers qu'on a
découvert la frontière russe à partir de
là les ukrainiens et le pouvoir
ukrainien a décidé que il fallait mettre
le paquet sur la justice même si on le
voit c'est très fragile mais il y a
quand même plusieurs procureurs et des
et des cas qui sont qui sont regardés il
y a plusieurs aspects à cela et je pense
que les auteurs de ce formidable
documentaire que nous a frappé toute et
j'espère tous les spectateurs aussi
peuvent en témoigner aussi il y a
plusieurs raisons à cela premièrement
l'Ukraine contrairement à ce qu'on peut
penser l'Ukraine reste un état
fonctionnel l'Ukraine a été l'état
fonctionnel tout au long dès les
premiers jours de l'invasion ce qui est
un exploit en soi décidément on en a
déjà bien parlé surtout madame
c'est que
la justice est un aspect extrêmement
important il ne s'agit pas que de
récupérer les territoires par exemple
d'avoir il y a aussi toute cette
dimension là
c'est une manière de répondre à
l'arbitraire de la barbarie de la
violence les Ukrainiens veulent répondre
par la justice exactement les messages
par ailleurs on peut voir ça aussi dans
la société ukrainienne les Ukrainiens ne
sont pas pour une sorte d'élanchage ou
pour des bonnes États à les Ukrainiens
sont pour la justice en elle-même par
contre là où je ne serai probablement
pas d'accord c'est que la justice est-ce
qu'elle est plus rapide ou plus longue
que d'habitude à ce que je constate moi
par rapport à ma connaissance au rythme
de travail de la justice ukrainienne je
suis
étonné de voir qu'en fait elle suit plus
ou moins son rythme normal plus ou moins
et ça c'est
l'officier russe Vadim a été jugé et ça
a été le premier
officier russe qui a tiré sur un
cycliste c'est très médiatique mais pour
une affaire aussi simple avec des
témoins et avec des preuves il y en
ayant un coupable c'était quoi c'était
un mois et demi de moi ça ça peut être
très rapide en effet à l'Ukraine mais
après une Bardet d'accord avec ça non je
suis pas je suis pas complètement
d'accord non chichi marine c'est chichi
marine effectivement c'est une affaire
simple
mais la question aussi c'est par exemple
ici on parle de crime internationaux
donc c'est ça aussi et l'intérêt aussi
c'est de voir si on peut remonter des
unités etc à l'histoire de chichi marine
moi ce qui d'abord il a été condamné à
perpétuité en première instance ensuite
ça a été changé alors il faut rappeler
un tout petit peu des faits donc c'est
officiers russes qui fuyant dans une
voiture
un cycliste civil et ça c'est
constitutif de crimes de guerre de tirer
sur un civil en conflit donc voilà je
suis d'accord que l'effet était assez
simple il les a reconnu etc très bien ça
a été jugé quand même en trois jours je
crois maintenant la question elle aurait
été intéressante de savoir quel est le
contexte de ça il y avait d'autres
personnes avec lui dans la voiture et
tout je dis pas ça pour le discréditer
lui mais où le décharger de sa
responsabilité mais c'est ça et et en
plus il y a eu la question de la peine
et je suis d'accord que au moins il y a
une vraie démarche d'aller dans la
justice et moi c'est ça je trouve
extrêmement moi je suis très admiratif
de l'Ukraine et comme vous le rappelez
aussi c'est vrai que c'est un état qui
reste fonctionnel alors malgré la
situation reprenons un tout petit peu
les termes et on va revenir au crime
sexuel mais crime de guerre pour que les
gens comprennent bien un crime de guerre
là on est dans une ampleur inédite
depuis il faut remonter à quoi la guerre
en Yougoslavie pour retrouver ce cette
ampleur là crime de guerre c'est quoi
c'est tout crimes qui est commis à
l'encontre d'un civil ou d'ailleurs ça
peut être aussi un mauvais traitement
d'un d'un prisonnier combattant toutes
ces formes là sur un terrain de conflit
quand on a un conflit ça constitue des
criminaires et les crimes contre
l'humanité les crimes génocidaires
supposent une intention politique
d'exterminer la population en partie ou
en totalité ou pas complètement mais de
l'exterminer dans son identité
collective c'est-à-dire dans son passé
qu'elle n'est plus de passer dans son
avenir or les viols entendent guerre où
il y a beaucoup de témoignages qui
montrent que le les acteurs disent tu
n'auras plus d'enfants ukrainiens et qui
sont d'ailleurs en lien avec cette idée
qu'on enlève aussi le passé le tyran
adore être présent pour l'éternité
jadis et à jamais et donc il aborde les
cimetières il brûle les livres d'écoles
d'historiens il change l'histoire et sa
façon d'envahir l'avenir imaginairement
l'arbre de filiation des des de la
communauté qu'il veut anéantir dont il
veut anéantir le la présence même s'il
ne tue pas tout le monde sait faire
l'enfant de l'ennemi c'est envahir
l'arbre de filiation c'est faire
l'enfant de l'ennemi à la femme pour
envahir l'avenir elle aura elle sera
rucifiée elle aura un russe elle est
mais c'est en même temps c'est
entièrement fou c'est une croyance et
pour les anthropologues le fils n'érite
pas des qualités morales du père il y a
pas voilà et la fille de la mère on voit
bien qu'il y a une dissymétrie il y a un
problème avec cette croyance dans la
question du crime sexuel en temps de
guerre la question c'est c'est on
comprend la dimension la signification
symbolique à laquelle vous vous référez
mais c'est la question l'intention et
c'est la question de l'ordre aussi alors
juste que je veux dire c'est que le mot
génocide qui a une définition très
sérieuse pour les juristes si on le
traduit c'est gainos naissance donc
l'assassinat de la naissance il me
semble que cette définition littérale
sans ambition modeste en quelque sorte
mais littéral peut être réfléchie aussi
au plan juridique c'est à dire que des
crimes les viols massifs jamais puni
encouragé en aura jamais les ordres mais
si on décore le bataillon qui a été à
bout de chasse et bien que on reconnaît
que les crimes étaient que tous ces
crimes sont licites et sont presque
applaudis et sont applaudis et donc ça
veut bien dire qu'il y a une dimension
avec ses violentes de guerre de
tentatives d'anéantir le l'avenir
imaginaire de la collectivité au travers
de la section donc l'anthropologue que
vous êtes ne dit pas comme on entend
beaucoup attention
génocide on verra qu'après si c'est
vraiment un génocide c'est trop tôt non
moi au contraire on est à un an de
guerre on a toute une série de
témoignages moi je suis la notion de
génocide a été inventée à cause de
l'exceptionnalité des crimes des nazis
il y a de l'exceptionnalité il faut être
souple il faut pas le considérer que le
National génocide d'une vache sacrée à
laquelle plus personne ne doit toucher
et donc ça protégerait tous les
génocides qu'on n'aurait pas le droit
d'appeler génocide pour 21e siècle merci
Claire de nous protéger les futurs
génocidaires et donc moi je suis pour
qu'on utilise c'est un outil c'est un
outil efficace et je pense que dans ce
cas là l'idée d'anéantir la nation
ukrainienne en tant qu'ukrainienne dans
lever les enfants de mettre des
passeports russes de les russifier c'est
une dimension
génocidaire non pas physique non pas là
bien sûr pas comme Hitler etc mais au
moins comment dire politique de le mot
symbolique ne serait pas adéquat mais en
tant que nationalité c'est anéantir un
identique collective anéantir une nation
toute entière en tant que nation et on
pourrait dire les femmes pour les crimes
sexuels les souliers même les hommes les
réduire au silence la question
maintenant on entend on entend
l'anthropologue mais c'est comment on
poursuit ça et sur quel fondement est-ce
que est-ce que un tribunal pénal
international spécifique est-ce que il y
a moyen de montrer de prouver que ça
fait partie d'une forme de chaîne de
commandement d'une atmosphère je vous
fais réagir mais on a retrouvé vous
savez les mots de Vladimir Poutine juste
avant l'entrée en guerre le fameux ma
jolie ça c'est quelque chose qui est
très impressionnant quand même ces mots
issus d'une chanson du folklore russe
adresse
qui on va les retrouver et lui dit en
gros ma jolie faudra supporter que ça te
plaise ou non voilà 7 février 2022 quand
on dit ça avec cette violence là est-ce
que c'est pas une forme d'autorisation
à l'horreur dans la chanson originale ça
s'adresse à une femme décédée dans son
cercueil
il en est Schulz est-ce qu'il y a au
fond une forme de de continuum entre le
chef du Kremlin quelque chose qui dans
les mots dans l'atmosphère on voit la
barbarie de ces soldats qu'on sort de
prison qui ont sont des assassins et le
terrain
pour l'instant ce qui ce qui commence à
émerger récemment en tout cas dans les
mots des procureurs sur place c'est que
il commence à parler de d'implication du
commandement notamment dans les crimes
sexuels dans les experts aussi qui sont
sur place comment ça parler d'un
faisceau d'indices sur le fait que dans
une trentaine de dossiers il y aurait
des signes de consentement du
commandement donc ça c'est des éléments
voilà les procureurs cite aussi par
exemple le fait qu'on ait retrouvé des
préservatifs que des soldats russes
revenus avec des préservatifs qui est la
torture sexuelle en détention avec la
torture sur les sur les sur les enfin
voilà sur les par électrocus sur les
organes génitaux pardon mais en revanche
c'est encore pour les experts qu'on a
suivi sur place c'est encore trop tôt
beaucoup trop tôt les enquêtes en sont
instad initial il y a pas encore de
preuves d'un plan préconçu etc il y a
une culture du viol il y a une
de la du bizutage où les jeunes gens
sont violés dans une grande violence
avec des morts et donc cette culture du
viol qui est étudiée qui est cette
imprimation entre la culture du KGB et
la culture des truand mais déjà ça génie
sinon passé la politique le monde
politique le discours politique rue de
du Kremlin de avec le pouvoir poutinien
la séduction c'est ce côté culture de la
viralité c'est des masculinistes russes
qui trouvent que le viol c'est une
performance et cette culture c'est comme
ça qui met l'humour de son côté la
blague etc les moqueries par pénétrer
toute la société
on va regarder la juriste parce que
c'est comme ça qu'on arrive pardon mais
c'est ça ce sont les auteurs ce sont des
éléments ce qui a dit putin aussi
évidemment évidemment d'abord quand on
parle de justice on parle de tribunal
quand on parle de tribunal on parle de
qualification juridique pardon de
ramener bien pardon j'entends j'entends
ce qui est dit sur la définition de
génocide mais aujourd'hui on a des
définitions juridiques dans lesquelles
il faut rentrer et il faut lier des
éléments qui constituent un crime à un
auteur de crimes c'est ça la justice
pénale alors vous allez nous dire
comment mais déjà vous avez une
expérience sur cette question là des
crimes sexuels dans les conflits à quel
conflits ça vous fait penser par le
passé ce recours au viol aujourd'hui en
Ukraine mais il y en a plein en fait on
la pense à la Libye on pense à la série
c'est comparable mais déjà ce qui était
dit là moi j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur
le viol des hommes en Libye
l'utilisation du viol et des d'ailleurs
des tortures sexuelles de toute forme
c'est pour ça que crimes sexuelle
effectivement c'est très important c'est
utilisé on l'a vu dans les Balkans en
Bosnie-Herzégovine le viol a été un
outil de génocide au Rwanda donc il y a
plein de situations aujourd'hui on viole
dans énormément de pays dans le monde
nous mon ONG on travaille sur le monde
entier on a une carte je vous invite à
regarder la carte donc oui bien sûr
après qu'on est là dedans mais il faut
trouver les moyens mais du coup pour
suivre mais simplement l'Ukraine on est
en plein conflit il y a un travail de
documentation qui est fait on voit qu'il
y a une forme de systématisation parce
que c'est ça c'est pas qu'une question
des ordres on a l'impression on cherche
l'ordre c'est-à-dire on cherche celui
qui aura écrit sur un papier allez-y
violet mais comme ce qui a été dit juste
avant c'est ce qu'on regarde c'est
est-ce que ces systématisé est-ce que
c'est répété est-ce que en gros à chaque
fois que les soldats russes arrivent
quelque part il y a des viols je pense
que ça c'est assez établi mais ça reste
à
affirmer quoi et c'est ça qu'il faut et
aussi le fait que au niveau des unités
au dessus dans la hiérarchie on laisse
faire si vous voulez c'est faire ça
c'est constitutif bien sûr vous pouvez
être poursuivi pour viol comme élément
constitutif de crime contre l'humanité
Mariana alors parce que on va sur le
terrain de de parallèle et à la fois de
la tradition de l'armée russe alors déjà
la
cette sortie de Vladimir Poutine avec ce
refrain de chansons et elle est déjà
très réminissante d'une chanson qui
avait été écrite pendant l'invasion de
la Finlande en 39 dont le refrain était
prendre nous sans la beauté donc on
traite Finlande comme une femme à violer
une femme belle donc moi le soldat russe
prend moi ce que c'est pour dire que en
réalité le viol est
caractéristiques une longue tradition au
sein de l'armée russe et non pas depuis
10 ans mais depuis des décennies on
rappelle par ailleurs tous les viols qui
ont été commis par l'armée soviétique
en Allemagne nazie on se rappelle que le
prétexte de l'invasion de l'Ukraine
c'était la prétendue des nazification
une sorte de réactivation de ce mode
opératoire avec le mode génocide a même
été employé par poutine au début aussi
tous les crimes de guerre y compris les
crimes sexuelles qui ont été commis par
l'armée russe a commencé par la première
guerre de Tchétchénie ou quasiment toute
la population homme femme enfant tous
les captifs étaient systématiquement
violés et on n'a jamais payé assez
attention à ce qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses dans tout ce que vous nous dites
et notamment sur cette culture du viol
en Russie maintenant comment on fait on
a l'impression Céline Bardet que il y a
déjà beaucoup beaucoup de d'enquête un
enchevêtrement de plein de strates
d'enquêteurs des ONG il y a la coup
pénale internationale il y a des il y a
des juristes internationaux ça il faut
le faire il faut se coordonner mais il
faut déjà faire vite pour recueillir les
preuves parce que celle-ci elles peuvent
disparaître ça vous êtes d'accord
là-dessus oui au moins sur le recueil
des traces non non mais c'est important
de évidemment que c'est important de
faire vite bien sûr mais mais après sur
la singularité des crimes sexuels et
c'est ce que le documentaire je trouve
aussi montre excellentement bien c'est
que il y a un traumatisme il y a une
peur des représailles en l'occurrence en
Ukraine actuellement mais ça je vais
vous dire c'est partout moi je travaille
dans le monde entier j'entends aussi ce
que vous dites mais dans tous les
conflits dans le monde aujourd'hui on
utilise qu'on en fait trop sur l'Ukraine
non mais je veux dire on parle beaucoup
de l'Ukraine aujourd'hui et tant mieux
enfin je veux dire ce qui se passe
mérite qu'on en parle c'est pas la
question mais c'est de comprendre que le
viol est devenu un outil un mécanisme de
la guerre et du conflit et
qu'effectivement il faut qu'on arrive à
prendre conscience de ça quel tribunal
comment poursuivre est-ce il faut
laisser la justice ukrainienne est-ce
qu'il faut un tribunal spécifique est-ce
qu'il faut essayer de poursuivre un
maximum de chefs devant la Cour pénale
internationale il y a déjà beaucoup
beaucoup de d'ouverture de procédures en
fait là aujourd'hui il y a le parquet
ukrainien qui est compétent il y a la
Cour pénale internationale Manon on
parle d'ouvrir un parquet européen pour
travailler au crime de d'agression qui
est autre chose et qui d'ailleurs va
concerner beaucoup plus Poutine et Léo
gradés je pense que le parquet ukrainien
peut très bien faire son travail après
la question elle va être ailleurs la
question elle va pas tant être de
documenter les éléments de preuve on en
a plein et les crimes sont absolument
multiples et horribles la question ça va
être l'analyse on oublie souvent ça qui
est triste criminel internationale il y
a l'étape d'analyse aujourd'hui on a
énormément d'éléments ça prend du temps
d'analyser tout ça de faire le lien dont
je vous ai parlé encore une fois la
justice c'est pour suivre un individu
donc il faut lier cet individu à ce
crime et donc voilà donc il faudra
déterminer la qualification aussi il
faut qualifier il faut donc tout ça
c'est un énorme de guerre
et l'agression comme la Cour pénale
internationale n'est pas compétente pour
l'Ukraine sur le crime d'agression on a
cette discussion de créer un tribunal
spécial je pense que la volonté aussi de
l'Ukraine en fait dans le fond et qui
est un tribunal spécial comme il y a eu
pour le laxougoslavie ou le Rwanda ce
qui permettrait peut-être je pense
d'être une solution parce que la Cour
pénale internationale il y a plus de 60
fois qu'aujourd'hui on en a 70 000
dossiers ouverts au parc ukrainien 75000
comment voulez-vous mais que n'importe
qui n'importe quel pays dans le monde
puisse travailler sur 70 000 ou 75000
dossiers c'est pas possible donc il faut
donc il faut des renforts il faut des
renforts juridictionnels avec des
tribunaux spéciaux et les aider et il
faut aussi par juste réfléchir aussi à
d'autres formes de justice à un moment
si on a des masses de crimes il y a
d'autres matières aussi de rendre de
justice il y a des commissions il y a ce
qu'on appelle la justice transitionnelle
il y a des toutes les victime
n'attendent pas que les auteurs de
crimes en prison c'était intéressant ce
qui est dit dans le documentaire cette
femme qui dit moi je parle parce que je
veux pas que ça arrive aux autres et moi
j'ai beaucoup de victimes dans le monde
aussi qui me disent parce qu'elles y
croient pas à la justice elle ne croit
pas surtout que voilà cette volonté les
auteurs des fesses soient poursuivies
d'ailleurs la plupart des procès
aujourd'hui se font par contre quand tu
masse avec quelques bruits parce que
l'Ukraine le permet mais le les
procureurs enfin laissent la politique
en ce moment c'est de dire on laissera
le choix à la victime est-ce qu'elle
veut un procès en Ukraine là maintenant
ou pas en fait parce qu'il toutes les
victimes n'ont pas envie forcément d'un
procès donc ça vous l'avez vraiment
ressenti les victimes avant tout elles
veulent parler pour que ça n'arrive plus
presque davantage que pour recevoir
la justice un procès c'est ça
complètement et puis surtout on parle de
75 000 crimes de guerre mais en fait les
crimes de guerre à caractère sexuel
quand on regarde dans l'histoire de la
justice internationale ce sont souvent
pas cela qui sont jugés en priorité et
donc du coup les victimes elles ne sont
pas naïves sur le cours que va prendre
la justice et nationale et
internationale donc alors vous aurez le
mot de la fin Véronique ils ont même
pour les viols en tant pis la justice
les procès ont une difficulté parce que
cette question d'épreuve cette question
du témoignage de la honte qui pèse sur
les victimes donc en temps de guerre
pour démontrer une chaîne de
commandement pour des pratiques qui sont
tacites qui sont en dehors du langage et
des écrits à mon avis excusez moi j'aime
à mon avis ça ça va être très très
difficile donc on peut comprendre que du
côté des victimes qui rêvent de justice
y est cette idée que témoigner faire des
films en attendant que le boulot de la
justice soit fait c'est déjà un premier
pas
énorme les choses soient dites dans le
travail de
reconstruction de soi de réparation ce
qui est intéressant dans le fait de
faire ces enquêtes alors que le conflit
continue c'est qu'il y a quand même
toute une question sur la récolte des
preuves on parle vraiment des crimes à
caractère sexuels parce que en fait les
femmes on va voir plus vite s'il y a eu
violent et puis il va y avoir tous
travaillent en open source avec les
téléphones les réseaux sociaux et que ça
a beaucoup changé les choses le
numérique ça change beaucoup les choses
aussi vous aurez le mot de la fin cette
fois-ci c'est sûr c'est important mais
la question que les gens se posent aussi
c'est est-ce qu'un jour Poutine pour
être traduit devant un tribunal pénal
international il peut possible s'il y a
un changement en tout cas il peut
l'accusation donc s'il y a un changement
politique il peut se retrouver devant un
tribunal mais aussi vite s'y retrouver
devant un tribunal mais la chose que je
voulais dire c'est que ce qui est très
important aussi c'est en fait d'être à
l'écoute de ces personnes là de ces
victimes de ce qu'elles veulent et de
ceux dont elles ont besoin et du temps
aussi dont elles ont besoin parce que
c'est ça l'hortense c'est pas le même et
les crimes sexuels c'est très difficile
elles ont besoin de temps il y a des
victimes qui peuvent avoir été violées
aujourd'hui et qui parleront bien plus
longtemps après et votre film leur donne
ce temps et cet espace de reconnaissance
merci beaucoup merci d'être venu
débattre autour de votre documentaire il
en échool c'est Marine Courtade merci à
vous c'est la fin de cette soirée
événement autour de la première année de
conflit en Ukraine bonsoir à tous